Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Jetzt ist bald WM in den USA. Was mit dir?
Ich will den Wahl zurück.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 555, da ist sie jetzt also endlich,
die Schnappszahl und Vorwahl und überhaupt vom 7.
Juni 2026, wir haben euch ein bisschen hängen lassen, es gab Terminschwierigkeiten,
wie ihr vielleicht gemerkt habt und ja, ist überhaupt irgendwas passiert in der Zwischenzeit?
Das ist die große Frage. Da werden wir euch jetzt drüber aufklären,
wer ihr alle im Fußballfieber seid. Habe ich gehört.
Die haben alle Fußballfieber. Am meisten dieser Infantini da,
oder wie der heißt, der da den Friedenspreis.
Der hat Fieber.
Boah, die haben alle Fieber.
Das stimmt. Temperatur, die haben alle Temperatur.
Alter.
Ja, man hat Temperatur oder man ist auf Temperatur. Das ist schon ein echter Unterschied.
Das Einzige, was mir Spaß an dieser WM machen könnte, wäre, wenn irgendein liberales
Land, der da irgendwie in den USA,
den Triumph hat und sich dann nachher von dem Präsidenten des Landes dann noch
beschimpfen lassen muss, dass sie irgendwie die USA nicht haben gewinnen lassen oder sowas.
Aber das wäre das Einzige, was mich an dieser WM noch reizen könnte.
Ja, und sind denn überhaupt liberale Länder noch dabei?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ja, also nee, das ist das andere.
Man kann auch nicht, man kann jetzt mit so einer Regierung auch nicht sagen,
wäre nett, wenn Deutschland mal gewinnen würde. Die treten ja leider auch nicht
in diesem wunderschönen pink-violetten Trikot an. Das haben sie auch nicht.
Also ich bin, weiß nicht, ich sehe da nichts. Ich sehe da nichts.
Tja, Mensch.
Also wenn die deutsche Mannschaft da irgendwie ein bisschen was...
Dann gucke ich mir vielleicht irgendwie ein Endspiel an gegen die USA.
Dass sie diese richtig den...
Aber, pff, ne. Irgendwie, ne.
Ja, gucken wir doch mal, was da an liberalen Ländern da ist.
Also Irak hätten wir da im Angebot. Iran, Katar, Saudi-Arabien.
Ja, dann finde ich Endspiel Iran-Israel oder sowas. Das würde ich gucken einfach,
weil das wird wahrscheinlich aufregend, aber...
Das wird schwierig werden. Weil Israel nicht qualifiziert ist für die Entrunde.
Da ist der Iran...
Dann müssen wir wohl gegen die USA spielen. Wollen wir mal gucken,
wer als erstes das Spielfeld freigibt.
Die Blockade vor dem Tor muss aufgehoben werden.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Überraschungen und Curaçao stößt vor oder Cap Verde oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee, man ist... Ja, oder also Mexiko. Mexiko soll es einfach gewinnen.
Also irgendeine... Also ich nehme das Land, was für... Also Iran, Mexiko...
Also die größte Blamage für...
Spielt Kuba mit? Nee, ne?
Nee, Kuba darf nicht. Also für die USA wäre es wahrscheinlich die größte Blamage,
wenn Iran gewinnt oder Kanada.
Aber es wird wahrscheinlich beides nicht passieren. Mal gucken.
Alle Fußball verrückt.
Ja, sollen sie mal machen.
Mich bringt die WM bisher noch nicht so nennenswert auf Temperatur.
Aber es ist einfach wie ein Kalt. Also, wenn die das im vernünftigen Land machen,
kann man sich das angucken, aber irgendwie Katar, USA, was kommt als nächstes, ey?
Ja gut, das findet ja auch in Mexiko statt und auch in Kanada.
Es ist ja nicht nur in den USA.
Ja, dafür hat er ja auch dann direkt den Friedenspreis bekommen.
Ja, mal gucken, ob es überhaupt noch genug Kerosin haben, um die Spieler durch die Gegend zu schicken.
Was mit meinem Wahl? Ich interessiere mich mehr für den Wahl.
Du interessierst dich mehr für den Wahl, dann kommen wir doch gleich mal zum,
Feedback, weil selbstverständlich hat das Thema Wahl euch nicht kalt gelassen.
Langhaarschneider kommentiert kurz, der Wal wurde von dem einen Timmy genannt,
weil er am Timmendorfer Strand lag, sehr kreativ.
Übrigens hat sich jetzt rausgestört, dass es sich um einen weiblichen Wal handelt.
Von den anderen wurde er Hope genannt, damit Nico Semsroth recht behält,
die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt, aber sie stirbt.
Florian fügt noch hinzu, Wale schwimmen zum Sterben in flache Gewässer,
damit sie dort liegen und atmen können, anstatt zu ertrinken.
Der Buckelwal ist nun sehr wahrscheinlich qualvoll ertrunken.
Ja, das, äh, ja, ja, also, ähm.
Ja, das ist leider so. Aber wir haben ein paar Hippies, die sich jetzt ganz,
die privatwirtschaftliche Wahlertrinkungsinitiative, also.
Ja, ja. Karl fügt noch hinzu, diese ganze Nummer mit dem Wahl zeigt auch eine
größere Bildungslücke in Sachen Ökologie in der Gesellschaft.
Die Rettung von Individuen hat in der Regel keinen Einfluss auf die Größe einer
Population. Die pendelt sich nämlich irgendwo um die Kapazitätsgrenze des Ökosystems ein.
Wildtierrettung ist mit Ausnahme von extrem bedrohten Arten,
von denen es nur noch sehr wenige Individuen gibt, also komplett sinnlos.
Wenn man den Tieren wirklich helfen will, setzt man sich für effektiven Artenschutz ein.
Das hat bei den Buckelwalen auch bestens funktioniert. Deren Population hat
sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten nämlich massiv erholt.
Und so ein Buckelwal-Kadaver ist Nahrungsgrundlage für eine große Zahl an Lebewesen.
Einfach liegen lassen ist also auch Artenschutz.
Das haben die Dänen ja auch gemacht. Also das ist so faszinierend,
wie wenn du dir die Berichterstattung erspiegelt.
Also es gibt irgendwie zwei so YouTuber, die sitzen, der Wahl liegt da,
dann bläht er sich irgendwann auf, weil er natürlich fault und dicht ist.
Der hat ja eine relativ stabile Haut.
Und dann waren da irgendwie so zwei YouTuber, die da irgendwie mit so einer
Kamera auf dem Stativ und die machen einfach 24 Stunden Livestream von dem scheiß Wahlkadaver.
Und es passiert halt einfach nichts.
Und die Däden sagen halt so, die Däden gucken so, was ist mit denen?
Also ich meine, die stören jetzt nicht, aber warum machen die das?
Die verstehen das halt überhaupt nicht.
So, was macht die deutsche Medienlandschaft? Schickt natürlich Interviewer,
Kameramann, seht euch diese beknackten Deutschen an, sie stehen am Strand und
filmen den Wahlkadaver.
Ohne zu merken, dass sie selber dazu gehören, da gerade hingefahren sind.
Und dann fand ich aber sehr faszinierend einen Bericht, was nämlich jetzt passierte, ist,
Die obduzieren den jetzt. So, und da sind dann Menschen gekommen,
die haben den obduziert, um, was weiß ich, um zu gucken, was die Deutschen ihn
da hingelegt haben, ja. Könnte ja auch ein trojanischer Wal sein.
Und dann irgendwie, ja, dann geht halt dieser Obduzent dahinter und schneidet
dann da in diese, also der ist da quasi das, was, ich weiß nicht, wie nennt man das denn?
Das genau. Dieser Bereich hier, dieser unterm Mund, das ist ja aufgequollen.
Hier so am Hals, da waren dann alle schon so.
Boah, jetzt geht es. Der hat so einen Hals, der war.
Ja, und dann hat er da halt ein Messer, dann wurde bei Spiegel relativ enttäuscht
berichtet, dass das jetzt nur leise gezischt hat und der nicht in die Luft geflogen ist.
Aber das fand ich tatsächlich faszinierend.
Und da waren dann halt Familien mit ihren Kindern und haben dann da diese öffentliche
Obduktion des Wals angeschaut.
Und dann kamen die Leute, das ist ja auch relativ viel Biomasse,
mit der man da arbeiten muss, dann haben die dann geschnitten und haben gesagt,
guck mal, hier ist die Leber von dem Wal und da sind jetzt Parasiten drin.
Und dann stehen die Kinder da und sagen, Leber, Parasiten, ekelig,
Wahlleber und dann sagen die als nächstes, guck mal, hier ist was,
weiß ich, nächster Organ von dem
Wal, Blinddarm oder was auch immer die da rausholen und das ist dann eine,
eine öffentliche Bildungsdarbietung, wo dann eben Eltern mit Kindern sagen,
ja, ist ja in Ordnung, da muss man gucken, dass der hier so,
wie so ein Wal von innen aussieht, weiß ich ja nicht.
Das kriegt man jetzt nicht bei uns mal einer. Das passiert ja wohl auch relativ häufig.
Und es wird dann eben als Bildungsgelegenheit genutzt.
Zu Recht. Ist ja auch eine.
Und Spiegel hat dann da irgendeinen hingeschickt, der mit seiner Mütze und seinem
Mikrofon an dem Wal steht und sagt so, ja, hier sind acht Leute,
die gucken sich das an, war aber keine Aufregung von der deutschen Aufregung hier, nichts zu sehen.
Und damit zurück ins Studio. Das haben wir in den Geschick.
Und die Leute fotografiert mit Porträt und so. Die können nicht davon ablassen.
Aber ich fand es auf jeden Fall sehr...
Ja, erfreulich zu sehen, dass sie das dann da machen, sich das irgendwie anschauen mit dem Wal.
Ja, also es ist, ich weiß auch nicht, was mit Deutschland los ist,
aber irgendwie ist dieses Land mittlerweile in so einem Zustand einer totalen Verstörung.
Also es ist einfach, hier ist irgendwie gar nichts mehr klar und die Leute,
also es fehlt einfach so, alles fehlt.
Also Deutschland hat derzeit einfach keine optimistische Vision der Zukunft,
keine Ahnung, wohin überhaupt die Dinge sich bewegen.
Man musste ja nur diese ganze Verkehrsdiskussion anschauen, sowohl Large Scale,
was so die ganzen Versäumnisse der Elektrifizierung und,
man hat so seine Solarindustrie einfach geopfert for nothing,
träumt immer noch von irgendeiner Verbrenner-Registration.
Und labert die ganze Zeit irgendwas
von Technologieoffenheit und es ist alles völlig am Thema vorbei.
Ja und dann kommt da so ein armer Wal und dann ertrinken wir den oder was, weißt du?
Ja, aber das ist dann so ein Ausgleich-Ding, weil man weiß einfach,
wir kriegen nichts hin, unsere Züge fahren nicht, unsere Infrastruktur,
jeden Tag wird hier eine neue Brücke gesperrt und muss wieder neu gebaut werden.
Nichts geht voran. Telekommunikation brauchen wir das Thema hier gar nicht erst wieder aufzumachen.
Man verliert den Anschluss überall, man ist eigentlich bei nichts mehr dabei,
und man weiß auch überhaupt gar nicht, was man will.
Also es ist halt einfach eine totale mentale Lehre, die sich hier irgendwie breit macht.
Und dann kommt so ein Wal und dann ergreifen die Leute so diese Gelegenheit
mit, jetzt tun wir was Gutes und jetzt sind wir zu was gut und jetzt retten wir diesen fucking Wal.
Wir retten Wal.
Naja, irgendeine Form der Erfüllung willst du doch spüren. Man spürt doch hier nichts mehr.
Du kannst doch diesem Land, kannst du doch Tittenclips anlegen und da passiert doch nichts mehr.
Du kannst...
Das kannst du mit unserem Kanzler nicht machen, weil der ist nämlich viel zu
dünnhäutig, im Gegensatz zu den Wahl.
Ja, weißt du, wenn dann irgendeiner sagt, wie wäre das denn mal,
wenn wir den austauschen, dann ist der schon so,
also ich meine, gut, der hat ja auch einen eigenen Maßstab für sein Losertum
und der weiß ja auch, dass er einfach verkackt gerade.
Aber dann reagiert der noch auf sowas.
Dann tadelt der dann diese Ja.
Aber dieser Kanzler ist doch auch nur das Symptom einer totalen Orientierungslosigkeit.
Also allein, dass so jemand wie Merz überhaupt in diese Rolle kommen kann,
sich zum Bundeskanzler wählen zu lassen, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass das dann auch noch getan hat.
Zwei Anläufe geworden. Naja, wollen wir mal nicht vergessen.
Das ist ja egal.
Ganz so schlimm ist es nicht.
Ja, aber man hat auch in dem Moment sich nicht nach weiteren Alternativen umgesehen
und versucht nochmal klar zu kommen. Sondern sie wird dann einfach durchgezogen
und man redet sich das die ganze Zeit schön.
Nee, es redet sich keiner schön. Ich meine, Tim, du musst auch sehen,
ich meine, Katharina Reiche, what the fuck, Alter?
Die geht sogar nicht, die Frau. Das ist für dich eine Bestrafung, die Frau.
Ich würde das jetzt nicht an der Person festmachen. Das Problem ist nicht die
Person, das Problem ist die Korruption.
Da kannst du doch von nichts anderem mehr reden, als von einer vollständigen,
das ist also, das ist so, das steht uns wirklich nicht gut zu Gesicht.
Oder halt perfekt, ne? Also, je nachdem, wie man es jetzt deuten möchte.
Es ist halt einfach ein Zeichen der Zeit. Es ist halt einfach ein Symptom der Hilflosigkeit.
Ja, aber stattdessen helfen wir dem Wal.
Warum streifen wir diese Personen nicht einfach ab und sagen,
Leute, geht uns aus der Sonne?
Ja, dann rollen wir die halt zurück ins Meer.
Ja, das ist nicht was mit Urlaub in Dänemark.
Lass uns die in Dänemark an den Strand legen, aber dort den Abend wahl,
ey, meine Güte. Nee, aber das, also das.
Die Leute sind ja auch so full of themselves, da könnte man auch mal reinpiksen
und ein bisschen Gas ablassen.
Ja, könnte man auch mal ein leises zischen.
Das leise zischende Entspannung.
Wenn der Furz entweicht, der übel riechende Nein, aber es ist wirklich,
ja, nee, macht wenig Spaß.
Wir haben noch Feedback bekommen,
vom Bundestag. Der,
Kantorkel hat ja im Rahmen der letzten Sendung noch live den Antrag nach IFG gestellt, dass er
gerne die via Signal-Messager an die Bundestagspräsidentin Julia Klöckner gerichteten
Phishing-Nachrichten sowie alle weiteren Nachrichten, die zwischen der Bundestagspräsidenten
und denselben Absendern ausgetauscht wurden haben wollte. Ja,
hat er vom Deutschen Bundestag.
Angefragt, ja, überfragt den Staat, das war noch während der letzten Sendung,
haben wir, glaube ich, auch erzählt, und den Antrag verlinkt,
da gab es natürlich jetzt eine Antwort, ja,
und diese Antwort, das ist auch symptomatisch, diese Antwort ist zwei Seiten,
ja, aber vor allem auf Seite zwei steht dann quasi die Ablehnung, ja,
also der Chat wird ungefähr sein, hallo Signal Support, gib mal PIN,
und dann sagt die ihren PIN, und dann ist sie weg, ja, so, und jetzt,
Sagen Sie, Ihr Antrag bezieht sich auf konkrete Informationen zum vermeintlichen
Phishing-Angriff auf den Signal-Account von Frau Bundestagspräsidentin Julia Klöckner.
Diese Informationen könnten dazu genutzt werden, Sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu umgehen.
Ja, allerdings nur, wenn Julia Klöckner ihren PIN seitdem nicht geändert hat.
Das müssen wir schon mal sagen. Also es ist also, dies könnte nicht nur abstrakte,
nachteilige Auswirkungen auf die Belange der Sicherheit des Parlaments zur Folge
haben, sondern auch ganz konkret den parlamentarischen Betrieb gefährden.
Eine Gefährdung der öffentlichen Sicherheit im Sinne des Paragraph 3 Nummer
1 C IFG und Paragraph 3 Nummer 2 IFG ist bei Herausgabe der erbetenen vermeintlichen
Informationen hinreichend wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt geben sie es nicht raus. Also das war ja zu erwarten, dass sie es nicht
tun. Aber die Begründung ist nicht stichhaltig.
Das ist einfach nicht stichhaltig.
Aber sie mussten halt antworten. Insofern, ey, sie kriegen auf jeden Fall,
eine gute Mode für, dass sie überhaupt geantwortet haben.
Ja, das ist schon mal glücklich.
Also ist schon mal nicht durchgefallen, aber ist auch ein bisschen mangelhaft.
Ja, kommen wir zu einem etwas größeren Themenblock rund um unser Lieblingsthema
und euer Lieblingsthema, überhaupt das Lieblingsthema von allen derzeit AI.
Und da kommentierte Hagen.
Hagen sagte, wenn ihr betonen wollt, dass die KI harmlos ist, dann bitte doch so.
Die tut nichts, die will doch nur trainieren.
Ja, wenn du trainierst. Und das ist, finde ich, auch in Ordnung.
Die lernt das noch. Sehr wissbeginn.
Na, wenigstens einer, der noch was lernt.
Einer, der noch was lernt.
Ja, der Rest hat sich ja dem Lernen offensichtlich komplett verschlossen.
Da ist halt die AI emsig unterwegs. Da wird Tag und Nacht reingeklotzt und die
Daten werden miteinander verknüpft.
Und alle haben eine Meinung dazu. Sogar der Papst.
Sogar der Papst, ja. Und damit eigentlich Gott. Gott und Jesus.
Und Maria und der Heilige Geist. und die...
Meinst du auch jetzt? Kommt ja jetzt wieder Jesus oder was.
Meinst du, die machen jetzt Plenum und diskutieren? Die sind doch immer auf Linie.
Mit wem?
Die Heiligen da.
Die Heiligen drei. Die Heiligen drei Faltigen.
Also der Papst hat gesagt so, er hat ein Manifest geschrieben.
Wenn der Papst ein Manifest heißt, dann heißt das Enzyklika.
Das ist die Magnifica Humanitas, wo er jetzt nochmal sagt, wie großartig der
Mensch ist und dass er sich durch die Verzweckung des Menschen durch Technik wendet. Und,
das ist ja sehr schön, das hat er zum Pfingstmontag. Pfingstmontag ist,
glaube ich, ein wichtiger Tag in Christentum, Pfingsten, das ist irgendwie mit
Jesus Auferstehung oder sowas.
Die Verzweckung.
Himmelfahrt, wie auch immer. Und er sagt, ja, dass also aus der katholischen
Soziallehre, natürlich kann
er sich irgendwie was anderes auf einmal anerkennen und sagt dann, dass er,
Dass er findet,
dass der Mensch das Wichtigste bleibt.
Und das hat schon auch Anknüpfungspunkte,
in der Netzpolitik natürlich. Also der spricht dann von Datenkolonialismus,
quasi jetzt Gesundheitsgenomen, Demografiedaten.
Es ist ja wirklich so, dass wir jetzt einige wenige Großkonzerne haben,
die mit diesen Massendatenmodelle trainieren und auf die Zugriff haben.
Wir haben natürlich Bezüge zum Überwachungskapitalismus und Schwachstellen der
Menschen, psychologischen Schwachstellen, die ja ausgenutzt werden.
Das ist diese Verzweckung des Menschen.
Profilbildung, Konformität, Selbstzensur.
Auf diese Aspekte nimmt der Bezug, man könnte fast sagen, ist einer von uns.
Das ist ja ein Problem, was wir hier fast jede Woche behandeln und das sieht er auch.
Der Papst, einer von uns.
Ja, und er benennt dann eben auch die digitale Almende als Thema.
Daten, Patente, Algorithmen, Infrastrukturen sind gemeinsames Gut und dürfen
nicht in den Händen weniger sein.
Und ja, das sind alles sehr,
schöne Thesen. Freut mich, dass Gott das aussieht.
Und das von einem US-Amerikaner.
Was? Ja, aber das ist ja von Gott jetzt.
Du meinst, der ist jetzt gar kein US-Amerikaner mehr. Der ist jetzt gewechselt sozusagen.
Neue Staatsangehörigkeit.
Aber es ja, ich finde es.
Ich finde es erstmal super, dass er sich überhaupt damit auseinandersetzt.
Also ich meine, wenn ich so zurückblicke auf die letzten Päpste,
die wir so hatten, also okay, sein Vorgänger war jetzt, sagen wir mal,
zumindest für die klassischen sozialen Themen auch durchaus empfänglich und,
hat da schon eine andere Agenda gesetzt.
Während hier der deutsche Papst Ratze komplett in seinen theologischen Standardwerken und,
dem Altertum irgendwie festgehangen ist und auf mich niemals den Eindruck gemacht
hat, wie auch die Päpste davor im Übrigen.
Dass sie sich wirklich in irgendeiner Form mit dem Hier und Jetzt beschäftigen.
Mit dem hier und jetzt, genau, auseinandersetzen. Und das tut er natürlich jetzt,
der Leo XIV., tut es ja wirklich auf eine Art und Weise, die anhört auf ist, würde ich sagen.
Also, dass er dieses Thema aufgreift, finde ich an sich schon mal bemerkenswert.
Seine Schlussfolgerungen finde ich auch bemerkenswert.
Und dass er sich also dort einmischt in diese Debatte und da auch sagen wir mal,
ja fast schon Voice of Reason ist, während jetzt sagen wir mal die anderen Player,
in der Welt, die ja in der Regel von Machtpolitik und von Geld getrieben sind,
also von Wirtschaftsorientierung und selten eigentlich auf so einer mentalen
Ebene, auf so einer philosophischen Ebene argumentieren.
Und deswegen finde ich das eigentlich mal einen sinnvollen Beitrag.
Und da kann ich nur sagen, also wenn das so läuft mit euch, dann ist vielleicht
auch dieser ganze Kirchenkram gar nicht mal so überflüssig.
Jetzt wird es aber ganz schön sportlich, Tim.
Da kann man das weitermachen. Das ist doch auch gut. Ich meine,
ich finde, jede Gruppe muss sich auch mal legitimieren, muss man sagen.
Nur weil die in 2000 Jahren auch mal einen halbwegs sinnvollen Beitrag leisten,
kann man jetzt nicht den kompletten Laden da auf einmal seine Daseinsberechtigung geben.
Naja, aber man kann ihnen ja mal ein paar Punkte geben in dem Spiel,
wenn sie jetzt auch mal ein Tor erzielt haben.
Wenn sie jetzt auf WM ist, müssen wir jetzt auch hier die Fußballgleichnisse herausholen.
Das ist ja auch legitim. Also zumindest haben sie sich jetzt mal fürs Turnier qualifiziert.
Gegen wen denn?
Na, gegen alle anderen. Die spielen mit, verstehst du? Die sind in der Verlosung, in der Debatte.
Also, ich weiß jetzt nicht. Also, da ist ja jetzt mal ein halbwegs netter Text
formuliert worden von jemandem, der ein ganzes Leben lang nicht gearbeitet hat,
und viel Zeit hatte nachzudenken.
Ist in Ordnung, ja. Und wenn das auf irgendjemanden jetzt noch wirkt,
aber ich meine ehrlich gesagt,
irgendein esoterisch-mystischer Mensch, der jetzt irgendwie da an die katholische Kirche glaubt.
Gott, dem würdest du noch nicht mal ein Kapitel in Logbuch Netzpolitik einräumen, oder was?
Nee, ich meine, das sind ja die einzigen, für die das jetzt Gewicht hat.
Ja, für jeden anderen ist es halt dieser alte Mann von der Sekte.
Ja, gut.
Trotzdem ist das ja jetzt ein sinnvoller Beitrag, wenn er von der digitalen Almende spricht.
Ja, ja, nee, nee, das soll er ruhig weitermachen.
Und so ein Begriff wie die Verzweckung des Menschen, das finde ich einfach mal
einen schönen Begriff, um mal so,
in drei Worten zusammenzufassen, was halt passiert, dass wir quasi zu Datendifferenten,
geworden sind und die Maschinen sich halt dann daraus selbst ernähren.
Also es ist ja einfach Matrix all over.
Genau, da sagt ja auch Anthropic direkt genau, weil das wird hier bald alles Skynet.
Und so erklärt sich dann auch, warum irgendwie dieser Anthropic-Gründer,
der war ja mit auf der Pressekonferenz vom Papst. Ach echt? Ja, ja.
Und Anthropic meldet sich zu Wort und sagt, ja, 80 Prozent von deren Code ist
von Claude geschrieben.
Finde ich halt zum Beispiel, genau.
Also 80 Prozent von dem Code, den sie jetzt hinzufügen, derzeit kommt aus der
generierten Maschine, ja.
Ja, wundert mich, dass es so wenig ist.
Das muss halt auch noch reviewt werden und sie meinen ja auch selber,
dass es jetzt auch erstmal eine Entwicklung der letzten Monate sei,
dass der Code, der überhaupt erzeugt wird,
mit der bestmöglichen Qualität von Code, den Menschen erzeugt haben,
mithalten können und dass sie auch davon ausgehen, dass das bis zum Ende des
Jahres die Menschen noch überholt.
Soweit ich das mitbekomme, kann man sagen, das klingt nach einem durchaus realistischen Ziel.
Es brauche aber noch die menschliche Urteilskraft, um auch Code zu bewerten,
beziehungsweise auch um überhaupt erstmal ein Ziel zu haben und eine Bewertung dessen vorzunehmen.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz für die Jüngeren unter uns,
unter unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern,
wo dieser Begriff Skynet eigentlich herkommt, das ist nämlich ein...
Eine Erzählung aus dem schönen Film Terminator mit Arnold Schwarzenegger,
der in den 80ern rauskam.
Und Skynet ist schlicht die Prämisse des Films, dass halt die Maschinen übernommen haben.
Skynet hat quasi alles unter Kontrolle und die Menschen müssen sich verstecken
und kämpfen die ganze Zeit mit Ratatazongen gegen fliegende Drohnenwesen.
Also hat durchaus einen interessanten Bezug zu der aktuellen Zeit.
Und SkyNet ist mittlerweile so das Synonym für, wenn die Maschinen selber weitermachen.
Und das ist auch durchaus etwas, was Anthropik für vorstellbar hält.
Also man hat ja jetzt schon diesen Fall, dass sich Modelle durch andere Modelle verfeinern.
Und Sie sehen das auch durchaus, dass diese rekursive Selbstoptimierung,
wie Sie das nennen, dazu führen kann, dass die Modelle auch irgendwann selbst Modelle entwickeln.
Und ja, das meinen sie, das könnte durchaus dazu führen, dass Menschen eben
die Kontrolle entzogen wird.
Und wir würden ja intuitiv dann erstmal sofort denken und sagen so,
na, wer wäre denn schon so doof, diesen Maschinen dann auch noch gleich Zugriff auf alles zu geben.
Das läuft ja da irgendwo im Rechenzentrum, da kann ja nichts passieren.
Und dann kommen halt so Vögel wie hier so Open Claw, diese Gemeinde und natürlich
auch so Phantasten aus der Politik, die der Meinung sind, man müsste jetzt alles
mit AI machen, weil das wäre ja mal total die Zukunft.
Wir müssen ja jetzt alle das Silicon Valley werden von AI.
Wie wir das ja vorher auch alle schon immer das Silicon Valley von Krypto und
Silicon Valley von was auch immer. Gerade jetzt mal wieder die informatische
Sau war, die durchs Dorf gerade getragen wurde und Industrie 4.0 und wie es alles heißt.
Und nie ist man irgendwann mal was geworden. Naja, aber trotzdem ist halt diese,
Blickweise von Anthropik, also ich finde Anthropik ist insofern immer ganz interessant,
als dass die eigentlich die einzigen sind von diesen ganzen,
Top-Playern, die sich überhaupt auf so einer,
ich will jetzt nicht ethisch-moralischen Ebene sagen, aber die sich, sagen wir mal,
die überhaupt bereit sind, sich über diese Konsequenzen von allem so offen Gedanken zu machen.
Sam Altman hat das am Anfang auch mal getan mit OpenAI.
Von Google hört man eigentlich in der Hinsicht irgendwie nix und von XAI und
Elon Musk natürlich schon gar nicht und Meta.
Aber ja, das ist definitiv eine Diskussion, die geführt werden muss und zwar
nicht nur vom Papst, sondern eben auch von der Politik und auch von der Wirtschaft.
Also die kurze Variante von Skynet ist ja, das wird als militärisches Ding gebaut.
Dann stellen die Menschen fest, oh, das hat aber jetzt eigenes Bewusstsein,
das geht aus der Hand, das müssen wir ausschalten.
Und dann löst Skynet ja einen nuklearen Krieg aus, weil die Menschheit ja die
primäre Bedrohung sind. Und das,
leuchtet ja auch ein, dass die Menschen die primäre Bedrohung sind.
Das ist nachvollziehbar. Auch ein Zeichen von Intelligenz, dass er langsam die,
Ich habe mir in den letzten Wochen durchaus ein paar Gedanken dazu gemacht,
was diese Technologie ist.
Oder was ich inzwischen in der Lage bin zu tun, mithilfe von dieser Technologie,
Dinge, die ich vorher nicht konnte und erst recht nicht in dieser Zeit.
Und da ist das Coden nur ein.
Sehr kleiner Teil von, weil diese Modelle halt sehr viel mehr können.
Und vor allem, was ich natürlich faszinierend finde, als jemand,
der ja quasi Intelligenzforschung auch gelernt und studiert hat,
dass das Ding sich halt auf Werkzeuge baut.
Und ja, das ist ja so, das ist das, wenn du jetzt so guckst,
also Intelligenz ist planvolles Handeln und dann sieht man irgendwie so,
dann guckt man sich Krähen an, die, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Nüsse auf die
Straße legen, weil da Autos langfahren und die Nüsse für sie knacken und so.
Das heißt, die können eine Konsequenz ihres Handelns vorhersehen und dann siehst
du dir Primaten unterschiedlicher,
Intelligenzstufen an, die planvoll handeln, die Werkzeuge bauen,
die Werkzeuge nutzen, die gezielt, wo du dann siehst, die nehmen einen Stein
für ein Problem, aber der Stein passt auch, die haben sich auch den richtigen Größe gesucht.
Also das sind ja dann alles so die Dinge, an denen man Intelligenz festmacht.
Und was ich sehr häufig jetzt.
In der Arbeit mit so Modellen, primär arbeite ich gerade mit Claude,
und feststelle, ist erstens das Bauen von Werkzeugen, aber auch über die Aufgabe hinausgehen.
Schon den nächsten Schritt mitdenken und sagen, pass mal auf,
wenn du das Inkonsistenz aufgefallen, ich glaube, das möchtest du so und so
lösen, sag mal eben, wo ich das schon mal direkt machen soll,
ich habe hier was gestellt und,
Über Dateigrenzen hinaus irgendwie, ach, das, um das herauszufinden.
Also das geht schon los mit so, hier fass mal bitte einen Spiegelartikel zusammen
und dann sagt er einfach, ah, Spiegel, ich habe versucht zuzugreifen,
die blocken mich, ich mache mal ein paar Recherchen und ich umgehe das einfach sofort.
Und es tut mir auch sehr leid für die Leute, die dann da irgendwie noch über
diese Technologie höhnisch lachen und sagen, das ist alles Slop oder so.
Also daran erkennt man halt, dass sie wirklich sich in diesen neuesten Iterationen
und mal mit ernsthaften Aufgaben, wie gesagt, unterschiedliche Dateiformate, irgendwas erledigen,
wirklich mal so eine Aufgabe, die einen normalerweise vielleicht wirklich mehrere Tage beschäftigt,
das ist da relativ schnell zu erledigen.
Und das ist schon.
Sehr, sehr beängstigend, also beeindruckend und auch beängstigend.
Und der Teil, der mir da nach längerem drüber nachdenken eigentlich am ehesten Sorgen macht, ist,
wenn ich jetzt anschaue, welche Aufgaben ich damit erledigen kann und was mich das kostet.
Ja, also wie viele Tokens, also wie viel Euro ich für die Lösung oder für diese
Unterstützung bei der Lösung einer Aufgabe ausgeben muss,
dann steht die sehr häufig in einem lächerlichen Verhältnis zu sagen wir mal
dem Produktivitätsgewinn.
Oder auch dem Mehrwert, den ich dadurch generieren kann. Also wenn ich irgendwas,
bei der Arbeit erledige, dann wird das, das kauft ja auch, also da werde ich ja auch für bezahlt.
Das heißt, da gibt es irgendjemand anders für diese Person oder Firma oder was
auch immer, generiere ich einen Mehrwert.
Und ein großer Teil von diesem Mehrwert, den trägt halt die KI bei,
in einer sehr kurzen Zeit.
So, das soll nicht heißen, dass ich den Mehrwert nicht auch hingekriegt hätte.
Das ist aber unerheblich.
Ich hätte halt länger dafür gebraucht. So, das heißt, wenn hätte ich das gemacht,
und hätte ich das zu, was weiß ich, zu irgendwelchen Stunden oder Tagessätzen gemacht,
dann hätte ich dafür so und so viel Geld in Rechnung stellen müssen,
Einheiten oder was auch immer.
Und jetzt mache ich die gleiche Arbeit an, sagen wir mal, in vier Stunden plus
Tokens für ein 20 oder sowas.
Und berechnen das natürlich immer noch das gleiche Geld, selbstverständlich.
Das ist nicht die Frage. Ich mache das jetzt bei mir am Beispiel,
weil das Problem ist, wenn das in allen oder in ausreichend vielen Branchen gleichermaßen so ist,
dann haben diese KI-Firmen ja jetzt etwas gebaut, was mit all diesen Branchen
gleichermaßen konkurriert und viel
zu billig ist, beziehungsweise oder sie enabled und viel zu billig ist.
Und die nehmen ja quasi dann zu wenig dafür.
Weil, sagen wir mal, es gibt einen Markt. Dieser Markt, der funktioniert jetzt.
Es ist eigentlich völlig unerheblich, was das ist.
Nehmen wir jetzt das Schreiben von Code. Nehmen wir das Schreiben von Code. Es ist unerheblich.
Weil die ja eh in jedem Markt gleichermaßen unglaubliche oder in großem Teil
der Tätigkeiten, für die Menschen Geld bekommen, gleichermaßen enorme Effizienzzugewinne liefern.
Inklusive, dass bestimmte Tätigkeiten halt obsolet werden, sehr zeitnah.
Schreiben von einfachem Code oder so.
Und wenn du jetzt etwas baust, was in vielen Wirtschaftsbereichen gleichermaßen,
die Kosten so weit runtertrichst, so unglaubliche Effizienzgewinne macht, dann,
ist es dumm als Unternehmen, das so billig anzubieten, wenn andere damit so viel Wert generieren.
Und es ist natürlich auch letztendlich schlecht für das gesamte Wirtschaftssystem,
weil das halt auf einmal kollabiert, wenn alles inflationär verfügbar ist,
woher soll jetzt noch das Geld
kommen, um diesen Mehrwert, der generiert wird, überhaupt zu bezahlen?
Also du brauchst ja, um das ein bisschen einfacher darzustellen, Henry Ford, als er,
diese Fließbandgeschichte und so weiter nennt, das als Fordismus bekannte Prinzip,
das hat er auch mit drin, dass er gesagt hat, die Menschen immer mehr im Fließband
stehen, die müssen genug Geld verdienen, um sich selbst auch so ein Auto kaufen zu können,
weil nur dann habe ich ein Wirtschaftssystem, was irgendwo in einem Gleichgewicht bleibt.
Unser Wirtschaftssystem ist eh schon vollständig aus dem Gleichgewicht raus,
ja, Kapital Akkumulation bei irgendwelchen Konzernen und Milliardären noch und nöcher, ja, ähm.
Und jetzt kommt in diese Welt eine Technologie, die nur einige wenige Konzerne
haben, die sich jetzt im Prinzip aussuchen können,
mit welchen Branchen sie in eine sofortigen Vernichtungskonkurrenz gehen wollen,
weil sie halt viel, viel, viel billiger sind.
Und wenn sie das aber tun und das mit zu vielen tun, dann,
glaube ich wirklich, dass mit einem derartigen Effizienzzuwachs überall bringst
du halt das Gesellschafts- und Wirtschaftssystem einfach aus den Fugen.
Weil du halt dann einfach diese ganzen handwerklichen Coder oder handwerklichen
Buchhalter, egal was, und dann geht jemand hin und sagt, okay,
das kann dieses Cloud einfach.
Also du machst einfach Millionen von Menschen, unterbietest du nicht um 10 oder
20 Prozent, sondern halt um 90.
Und dieser Effekt, der ist zu stark, als dass dann eine Gesellschaft und ein
Wirtschaftssystem stabil bleiben könnte.
Entsprechend würde ich davon ausgehen, dass sie sehr, sehr, sehr zeitnah,
wenn der Markt dann verteilt ist, die Preise wieder anziehen.
Ich meine, das haben, wenn jetzt das erste Mal, dann haben die Cloud-Unternehmen ja genauso gemacht.
Cloud war hier viel billiger, viel billiger, bis alle drin waren und dann war
das auf einmal nicht mehr billiger.
Dann hat man gesehen, ach, jetzt kommst du nicht mehr raus, stellt sich raus mit Preise hoch.
Also das wäre der glimpfliche Ausgang, dass wir jetzt irgendwie in so eine Monopolstruktur
internationaler Milliarden-Zentralkonzerne gehen, die dann gnädig dafür sorgen,
dass sie den größeren Teil der Marge bekommen und wir nur noch langsam um 10%
besser werden damit oder um 10% billiger werden damit.
Damit das nicht alles aus dem Fugen gerät.
Weißt du, dann bauen Leute Maschinen. Gut, dann hast du Dampfmaschinen.
Gut, Industrielle Produktion wurde besser in Ordnung.
Und dann war klar, niemand wird die industrialisierbaren Bereiche industrialisieren,
sonst wird die Konkurrenz sie fressen, weil sie halt effizienter ist und billiger und so.
Aber das sind halt einzelne Bereiche gewesen und nicht halt die gesamte Gesellschaft.
Und jedes Geschäftsmodell oder jeder...
Alles, was es gibt.
Naja, also das Disruptionspotenzial, denke ich, ist klar geworden.
Das ist real. Ich frage mich allerdings, ob es schon so ausgemachte Sache ist,
dass am Ende, okay, ein Ende wird es in dem Sinne nicht geben,
aber dass, sagen wir mal, jetzt in der nächsten Zeit sich,
das so unbedingt für die derzeitigen Vorreiter so ohne weiteres auszahlen wird.
Wenn die so weitermachen, nicht. Die müssen die Preise erhöhen.
Ja, wenn die so weitermachen und wenn alle anderen nicht so weitermachen.
Aber alle anderen machen ja auch weiter. Also ich meine, wenn wir jetzt von
den Platzhirschen reden, dann ist es halt auf der einen Seite sind es Unternehmen
in den USA, vor allem natürlich OpenAI, Anthropic,
Google und mit Einschränkungen vielleicht auch noch Meta, XAI,
denke ich mal, ist zum Wesentlichen einfach nur Fake.
Aber auch die Chinesen sind halt sehr gut unterwegs und bringen da sehr gute
Models bei raus und vor allem gibt es halt auch noch parallel dazu eben diesen Trend der lokalen,
Models, also die man quasi auf seine eigenen Computing-Infrastruktur laufen lassen kann.
Die sind natürlich derzeit nicht konkurrenzfähig in der Geschwindigkeit.
Die jetzt so riesige Datacenter, wie sie überall jetzt aufgemacht werden,
bieten können, indem sie hochparallelisiert diese ganzen Aufgaben auf viele Maschinen verteilen.
Aber die Fähigkeitenlücke, die schließt sich zumindest derzeit mehr.
Also nicht geschlossen.
Die Frontier-Modelle, also die großen Top-of-the-Line-Modelle,
die sind schon noch weit voraus. Und man kann auch sagen, da ist vielleicht
auch Anthropic nochmal so ein Tippelschritt weiter als die anderen.
Kann sich aber jederzeit auch ändern.
Aber wir werden auch sehen, dass es,
nicht unbedingt Open Source, aber man nennt es ja Open Weight,
also so eine allgemeine problemlose Verfügbarkeit von Modellen,
die good enough sind, die man auf eigener Hardware bauen kann,
wenn man sie dann irgendwann mal wieder bezahlen kann.
Derzeit ist das ja nochmal so ein anderes Problem. Also ich sage nur,
dass es nicht ausgemacht, dass das unbedingt so kommen wird.
Es ist definitiv eine Möglichkeit, dass es so kommen wird.
Ist aber, glaube ich, kann man jetzt noch nicht so ohne weiteres vorher sagen.
Wenn die frei verfügbaren Modelle diesen Grad an Capability erlangen,
dann haben wir aber eigentlich noch viel größeres Problem.
Weil dann wird diese Inflation ja erst recht allenthalben einsetzen.
Ja gut, aber dann haben auch alle diese Mittel.
Ja, aber es muss ja irgendwo, also irgendwo muss auch, also ...
Wenn man ein Wirtschaftssystem hat, dann muss ja irgendwo auch noch,
irgendwo muss ja dieser ganze Mehrwert generiert werden und,
der, der sich in Umlauf befindet, ja, also irgendjemand muss etwas,
etwas wert sein, damit du so eine Dienstleistungs- und Produkte und so weiter,
dass das alles hast, ja, dadurch funktionieren, oder also,
was heißt dadurch, so funktionieren diese Systeme, ja, irgendwelcher Austausch,
was, du holst dir irgendwas von jemand anders, weil du es selber nicht kannst, ja.
Und weil es Leute gibt, die sich auf irgendetwas spezialisieren und so weiter und so weiter.
Alles gut, aber du brauchst halt irgendwo auch noch Leute, die das Geld.
Also irgendwo muss dieser Mehrwert auch wirklich noch entstehen und das Vermögen
sein oder das Geld sein, um den bezahlen oder haben zu wollen.
Und wenn das in die eine oder in die andere Richtung aus dem Gleichgewicht kommt,
dann kommen, also weiß ich halt nicht, Dann flippen halt so ein paar Sachen um.
Und was die Rechnung, die er jetzt natürlich gerade noch außen vor lässt,
ist, weil natürlich relativ viele
Leute verstanden haben, was für absolut mächtige Technologie das ist.
Unsere Bundesregierung nicht, aber einige ja schon.
Sowohl diese Firmen, die das machen, die halt jede Milliarde da reinwerfen und
ob das jetzt eine Bubble ist oder nicht, ist eigentlich völlig egal.
Es geht halt um die technische Vorherrschaft, spätestens auch in einem.
Ja, eigentlich in der Weltbeherrschung. Ja, bist du China oder USA und blickst
du halt auch wirklich auf diesen,
Systemwettkampf und diesen Anspruch Weltherrschaft, das ist ja der Anspruch,
den die stellen, dann kannst du natürlich nicht dulden, dass irgendjemand anders,
diese Technologie hat und du nicht oder eine bessere als du.
Das heißt, da wird es vorangetrieben.
Selbst wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Land sagt, ach ja, wir sind jetzt hier,
was weiß ich, Deutschland, wir machen das ohne KI, wir machen Verbrenner und kein KI.
Dann in dieser globalisierten Welt dann bis in der Steinzeit.
Und ich bin wirklich sehr.
Gespannt, also es könnte ja auch, um den Bodenbogen mal zu Ende zu erzählen,
vielleicht kann das ja auch sein, das wird ja demnächst einfach,
das ist eine alte Forderung des CCC Automatisierungsdividende,
dann kriegen wir demnächst alle schön unser,
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, einfach nur damit noch Geld im Wirtschaftssystem
ist, was man verteilen kann.
Und dann bist du entweder im Open AI oder im Anthropic-Ökosystem oder wenn du
ganz verwegen bist, in irgendeinem chinesischen Modell, was dein...
Was dich beschäftigt, was irgendwie guckt, dass du, also es ist ja wirklich,
stell dir mal vor, deine Produktivität wird nicht mehr gebraucht,
dann ja, dann redet das halt mit dir, das steuert deinen Haushalt,
guckt, dass du glücklich bist und versucht dich dahin zu modellieren,
dass du dir das Geld zurückgibst,
was man dir anvertraut hat zum Ausgeben oder so.
Ich meine, dass Technologie das Wirtschaftswesen immer wieder komplett umgewälzt
hat, ist ja in dem Sinne jetzt nichts Neues.
Das haben wir irgendwie mit Telekommunikationen gehabt, das haben wir durch,
neue Energieformen, durch Transportwesen.
Also es gibt immer wieder so eine technologische Entwicklung,
das Internet, Computer an sich natürlich auch,
Smartphones, die also immer wieder Dinge,
die bisher getan wurden im Wirtschaftsleben, vielleicht nicht obsolet gemacht
haben, aber zumindest so ein bisschen die Bedeutung geändert haben,
teilweise auch obsolet gemacht haben.
Und du hast natürlich recht, jetzt bei AI betrifft es halt auf einmal so einen
Bereich, mit dem man so nicht gerechnet hat, dass das sozusagen diese originären Tätigkeiten des,
Menschen im Sinne von Nachdenken, Strukturieren,
Sammeln, Recherchieren, Auswerten und so weiter auf einmal betrifft.
Auf einmal geht es so sehr an das heran,
von dem wir glauben, dass es uns primär auch ausmacht, wo wir uns irgendwie
immer so toll und besonders gefühlt haben. und aus.
Schon auch zu Recht, ja.
Ja, aber so nicht. Also da geht es auf jeden Fall ran und,
das ist natürlich sehr unangenehm, weil es ja dann auch so den eigenen Stolz
auch nochmal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise trifft, aber ich würde jetzt
nicht sagen, dass da keine Adaption gibt. Es ist natürlich,
Die Geschwindigkeit, mit der das jetzt läuft, ist bemerkenswert.
Also ich denke, dass wir beide nicht, jetzt haben wir 26, wann ging der Spaß
los? 22, also vor vier Jahren.
Sagen wir mal, vor der Veröffentlichung von GPT-3.
Nein, glaube ich, hätte niemand von uns das so für möglich gehalten, was jetzt Realität ist.
Und auch das, was jetzt Mitte 26 die Realität ist, da konnte man auch letztes
Jahr schon noch dran zweifeln.
Ja, also die ganze Entwicklung ist extrem exponentiell und von daher ist auch
sehr schwer einzuschätzen, wann wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich einen Sättigungsgrad mal erreichen.
Also ob wir jetzt hier wirklich gegen eine Wand laufen, irgendwann technologisch
mit, okay, das war es jetzt, bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Oder ob wir uns eigentlich gerade
erst am Anfang dieser Beschleunigung befinden. Schwer zu beantworten.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo dazwischen.
Was die Anthropic-Leute ja im Prinzip sagen, ist, naja, also,
eine,
eine Was sollte diese Entwicklung beschränken?
Du könntest sagen Energieverbrauch, Hardwareverfügbarkeit.
Höchstens verzögern.
Genau, aber also warum, also was sollte eine Weiterentwicklung,
ein Plateau jetzt noch herbeiführen?
In der, also ich merke das ja selber im Umgang mit, so wie ich so arbeite,
du kannst, natürlich kannst du effizient damit arbeiten, du kannst auch ineffizient damit arbeiten.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine vernünftige Architektur hast für deine Problemlösung,
was auch immer du da gerade baust und das Modell anweist,
zum Beispiel bestimmte Software oder Skripte oder Tools sich zu bauen und die
beizubehalten, zurechtzulegen und zum Beispiel zu sagen, bau dir einen da,
bau dir einen da, bau dir einen da.
Alles Dinge, die es ja auch schon längst gibt mit MCPs und was nicht.
Und dann kannst du als nächstes hingehen und sagen, okay, im Sinne,
der Effizienz, liebes, großes, kluges Modell, weißt du jetzt mal diese weniger,
effizienten Modelle, die ich bei mir habe, an und delegierst mal Aufgaben dahin.
Das heißt, du wirst, ich glaube, da ist noch relativ viel zu holen.
An Effizienz, Zuwachs, einfach nur dadurch, dass du bewusst mit den Computing-Ressourcen umgehst.
Und das fände ich jetzt tatsächlich für das Pricing, wenn ich so eine Firma
wie Anthropic betreiben würde, eben sehr spannend, ob man sagt, okay….
Dann berechne ich nach Token und sage, okay, wenn ihr damit ineffizient umgeht,
dann kriegt ihr halt eine hohe Rechnung und wenn ihr damit effizient umgeht,
kriegt ihr halt eine niedrige.
Wo was mir nicht gefallen würde ist, dass ich halt dann nicht genau weiß,
für wen arbeite ich da gerade und was weiß ich ruiniere ich gerade irgendeine
Oma die nicht gut prompten kann und eigentlich nur ihr, weißt du,
irgendwie ihr Testament schreiben will,
also eine Person die eine von der ich nicht viel Geld nehmen kann oder sollte,
oder habe ich es auf der anderen Seite mit einem großen Konzern zu tun,
der unglaublich gut da drin ist, mit meinem Tool effizient umzugehen,
und möglichst wenig Tokens zu bezahlen.
Und das wäre ja eigentlich schlecht für mein Geschäftsmodell,
weil eigentlich will ich ja von dem Konzern, der ganz viel mit mir verdient,
viel Geld haben und von den Leuten,
die wenig Geld haben, denen vielleicht möglichst effizient viel geben.
Und die Lösung, das zu tun wäre, dass du den Menschen das aus der Hand nimmst,
dass sie mit deinem Agent auf ihren Rechnern selber bauen.
Sondern, dass du sagst, wir lösen das Problem für dich und wir lösen das,
wir rechnen aber nicht nach Token ab, sondern nach Mehrwert,
den wir für dich generieren.
Wie willst du den bewerten?
Hast ja genug. Dein Modell wird ja wissen, was das da gerade tut.
Also, weißt du, Also Daten haben die und die können auch ganz gut mit Daten umgehen. Und das ist...
Ich gehe eigentlich sogar so weit, dass ich eigentlich, also vor ein paar Monaten
wurde das andiskutiert und da war dann irgendwie auch am Stockmarket,
dann sind die ganzen Softwarehersteller gefallen,
weil so ein bisschen gesagt wurde so, warum sollte man eigentlich noch Software haben wollen?
Warum sollte in zehn Jahren noch jemand ein Programm kaufen?
Und inzwischen frage ich mich das auch, weil die Programme, die ich haben will,
die lasse ich mir schreiben, beziehungsweise sage, leg sie bitte als Tool in
deinen Werkzeugkoffer und du hast jetzt ein Skill und wenn ich das nächste Mal
will, dann machst das bitte auf dem Weg, den du dir hier gerade gebastelt hast.
Nämlich mit diesen Python-Skripten über diesen MCP, der an deiner Hand ist und, und, und, und, und.
Ja, da wird sich dann entscheiden, was effizienter ist. Das jedes Mal wieder
neu auszuknobeln und quasi nur noch in so einem AI-Dauerzustand zu arbeiten.
Oder ob man eben nur die AI nutzt, um sich Werkzeuge zu machen,
die dann eben in ihrer Tätigkeit auch nachvollziehbar sind, replizierbar sind.
Man weiß, man tut das jetzt auf diese Art und Weise und dann ist das in gewisser
Hinsicht auch stabil. Da kann man sich nämlich jetzt bei reinen AI-basierten
Prozessen so sicher nicht sein, prinzipbedingt.
Von daher denke ich mal, wird es eine Mischung von beiden sein,
aber es kann gut sein, dass die Bedeutung von Software insgesamt sich verlagern.
Also Software wird natürlich nach wie vor wichtig sein, weil am Ende ist das das, was läuft.
Die Frage ist nur, was ist die
Herkunft dieser Software? Zahle ich für ein Office mein Leben lang oder,
verbringe ich ein Wochenende am Rechner und sage, baue mir mal hier mein Behörden-Office-System
für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland? Kriegt ja sonst keiner hin.
Jetzt haben wir endlich mal hier ein Gesundheitssystem.
Niemand wollte jemals ein Office haben. Die Leute wollten fettige Dokumente.
Also es gibt ja keinen, der sagt, ich möchte eine Tabellenkalkulation,
einen Texteditor, einen Dokumenteneditor und ein Präsentationsprogramm haben.
Ne, die wollen eine Präsentation, denen ist ja scheißegal, mit welchem Programm das ist.
Und gerade bei diesen, also wenn egal welche Software du kaufst,
ich meine Tim haben wir von dir diese ganze Buchhaltungsscheiße da aufschwatzen lassen Na, na,
na, na Finanzamt hat auch noch ein Wort mit geredet aber wenn du jetzt mal überlegst,
da hast du ein Softwarepaket mit,
keine Ahnung sagen wir mal, wenn das 1000 Funktionen hat,
dann brauche ich davon 10, also ich brauche vielleicht irgendwie so ein Prozent,
vielleicht auch fünf Prozent.
Der Rest ist einfach nur User Intervention. Von mir aus brauche ich auch zehn
Prozent, aber garantiert nicht annähernd 20 Prozent von dem,
was diese Software kann.
Der Rest ist einfach nur Klatter, der einfach zu meinen Prozessen nicht passt,
zu meinen Ansprüchen nicht passt, der mir einfach nur im Weg ist.
Und der mich ja sogar behindert, weil ich ihn nicht verstehe oder weil er irgendeinen
Scheiß in dem Feld ausfüllen oder so.
Und ich will ja auch ich will keine Buchhaltungssoftware haben,
sondern ich will eine fertige Steuererklärung.
Und wenn du das dahin, wenn du dahin gehst, und das ist Leuten ja sehr viel
wert, also die Dienstleistung, dass etwas fertig ist, da geben Menschen gerne Geld für aus.
Die tragen dann nämlich nicht, die stellen sich nicht in so eine scheiß Software
hin und beschäftigen sich damit, sondern die tragen ihren Schuhkarton mit den
Belegen, ziehen sie in der Steuerberatung und sagen, mach fertig, ist mir scheißegal.
Und diese Und.
Wenn sich die, wenn das Interfacing mit dem Computer, das hat sich in vielen
Bereichen ja jetzt schon dahin bewegt, wenn du jetzt beispielsweise mit Claude arbeitest.
Also du möchtest deine Steuererklärung demnächst von der AI machen lassen.
Ich rede, es geht nicht um meine Steuererklärung, es geht darum,
wie arbeiten Menschen mit Computern?
Und werden Menschen in Zukunft noch sagen, ich installiere ein Programm oder ist das nicht alles?
Wir haben ja auch schon in vorherigen Episoden drüber gesprochen,
wenn jetzt die Smartphone-Betriebssysteme sagen, so, wir haben jetzt hier übrigens
AI und eure Apps sind jetzt bitte so gestaltet, dass,
ihr exposed jetzt bitte neben den APIs in Richtung Betriebssystem,
die ihr da konsumieren dürft, exposed ihr übrigens folgende APIs in Richtung
unserer KI oder folgende MCPs, damit unsere KI direkt,
die Nachrichten senden kann oder den Kalender bedienen kann oder was nicht alles. Und.
Weil die wenigsten Menschen gesagt haben,
als sie gedacht haben, ich bräuchte einen Computer, um etwas zu tun,
haben die wenigsten Leute gesagt, ich will ein Programm für das,
ein Programm für das, ein Programm für das.
Und gerade in der Wirtschaft, also da, wo Menschen, was weiß ich,
arbeiten oder etwas bauen, generieren, Prozesse abbilden.
Werden Prozesse abgebildet über, was weiß ich, eine Reihe an Programmen,
die miteinander reden müssen und das ist kacke und hier und da hat wieder einer
jetzt Update und jetzt hat mir einer eine Excel-Tabelle geemailt,
die muss ich jetzt in, so.
So, eigentlich wollen die Leute ja einfach irgendein Ergebnis haben und die, die, die,
sagen wir mal Geschäftsprozesse, die sich in irgendwelchen unterschiedlichen
Programmen, wo zwischendurch Menschen dann tippen und das nennt man ja neuromechanische
Verarbeitung, sie müssen dann mit dem Gehirn auf die eine Hälfte des Bildschirms
gucken und in der anderen tippen.
Und um dann die Lücken zu füllen zwischen diesen Programmen und jetzt habe ich
das exportiert, jetzt importiere ich das hier und nein, musst du anders machen,
musst du den Haken setzen und,
weißt du, wenn das einfach alles weg ist und du sagst halt so,
ja mach mal dieses, jenes und hast dann so eine, wie heißt dieser schöne Film?
Blade Runner, ne? Einfach mit dem Computer reden, der hat auch nicht gesagt,
Computer, mach mal jetzt das Bildbearbeitungsprogramm auf und zoom da rein.
Enhance.
Handwerkzeug. Nein, das ist einfach, es funktioniert.
Und es ist, glaube ich, relativ, schon relativ absehbar, dass das Ubiquitous Interface,
natürlich die Vision ist, nach der jetzt alle streben und ich glaube, für viele,
In Anwendungsbereiche,
des Lebens ist es relativ einfach zu bauen. Und im wirtschaftlichen Bereich,
da wo es jetzt um produktive Dinge geht, da sehe ich halt diese Anthropic-Tools,
auch schon enorm auf dem Weg dahin.
Und nochmal, das Ding will ja nur trainieren. Alles, was du dem,
also jetzt außer dein Elixier-Kram, das interessiert nur wirklich keinen,
aber alles andere, was Leute machen,
bringen sie dem Ding ja dann auch direkt bei. Also jedes Mal,
wenn das ein Problem für dich löst, sagst du ja dann auch immer noch,
wie das richtig gelöst wird.
Also das Mensch-Maschine-Interface wird sich auf jeden Fall nachhaltig ändern in diesem Jahrzehnt.
Das ist ganz offensichtlich. und es ist auch offensichtlich,
dass die Science-Fiction sich was Neues einfallen lassen muss,
weil ich glaube, die Technologie kommt gerade ganz gut hinterher.
Da brauchen wir mal wieder neue Visionen, weil die alten sind jetzt,
glaube ich, langsam durch.
Ja, das ist jetzt echt langweilig. Das ist jetzt langsam mal kalter Kaffee.
Gut, lass mal weiter im Kontext. Wir haben ja noch ein bisschen mehr AI-Aspekte zu berichten.
Ja, es gibt dann natürlich interessante Messwerte in dem Bereich. Ja, jetzt,
Der ist Leiter von Cloudflare, Matthew Prince, hat jetzt, und Cloudflare ist
dieses Unternehmen, was ja, also okay, was macht Cloudflare,
ist ein Hochverfügbarkeitsproxy für,
was weiß ich, alle möglichen Webseiten.
Das heißt du hast irgendwie einen Server, der ist irgendwie halbwegs der hat
begrenzte Ressourcen du möchtest aber eine Webseite haben, die Inhalte überall auf der Welt,
schnell verfügbar macht und
gegen DOS-Angriffe geschützt ist und damit letztendlich in Peaks in Peaks,
viel mehr Kapazität hat als dieser eine Server, den du da hinstellst oder dieser
eine Infrastruktur, den du da hinstellst dann klopfst du halt Cloudflare davor
aus deinem Hochverfügbarkeitsdienstleister der,
sicherlich einen sehr großen Markteinteil hat, wenn nicht der Marktführer ist,
und ein großer Teil des Internet-Traffics geht halt am Ende durch deren Server,
bevor es die, wenn es überhaupt noch die, die dahinter trifft.
Auch eine beunruhigende Entwicklung, aber was das Entscheidende ist,
der sagt halt naja, wir sehen inzwischen mehr Traffic von Bots als von Menschen
also das Internet of Things,
oder das Internet of Bots ist jetzt halt,
ist jetzt halt real die Webseiten werden eher noch von,
von AIs gelesen und das ist, ich komme mir schon vor wie so ein Zeitungs-OP,
wenn ich dann morgens meine Browser-Tabs aufmache und dann lasse ich Spiegel
Süddeutsche Zeit und heiße und diese einzelnen Seiten und dann blätter ich da
um und klicke links und so,
statt einfach morgens meinen OpenAI-Chat anzumachen und mir erzählen zu lassen,
was ist und Nachfragen zu haben und zu sagen,
so einfach viel natürlicher zu Interfacen.
Ja, Opa erzählt vom Krieg, ne? Damals haben wir noch Webseiten selber gelesen.
Da haben wir noch HTML selber programmiert, da wussten wir. Mit PHP haben wir dann...
Ach ja.
Ja.
Also wie cool das dann aber auch rüberkommt, wenn man immer noch Kommandozeile
benutzt, weißt du? So drei Generationen noch davor.
Cloud Code offiziell ihr ausführst, oder was? Wuiuiui, wenn man das Terminal benutzt.
Naja, also da sieht man also auch schon, wenn das in den Messwerten schon ist,
dass halt der größere Teil des Web-Traffics oder also mehr als 50 Prozent des,
Web-Traffics jetzt schon von derartigen Bots ist.
Ja, ist krass. Also es kann gut sein, dass irgendwie die automatischen Systeme,
ich meine, da sind wir wieder bei dem Skynet-Thema. Die Maschinen unterhalten
sich jetzt mehr untereinander, als das die Menschen tun.
Kann auch vielleicht ganz gut sein. Also mich erinnert das so ein bisschen,
oh Gott, da sind wir wieder bei Science Fiction.
Douglas Adams, sagt er ja was, sehr bekannt, Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy,
hat aber noch ein anderes schönes Buch geschrieben, das hieß Der elektrische Mönch.
Und der elektrische Mönch, also ein elektrischer Mönch, so erzählt Douglas Adams
zu Beginn dieses Buchs, ist ein Gerät wie ein Anrufbeantworter oder eine Waschmaschine.
Und ein Anrufbeantworter, der nimmt für dich die Telefonate an und eine Waschmaschine,
die wäscht für dich halt deine Wäsche.
Und ein elektrischer Mönch ist ein System, was Dinge für dich glaubt,
damit du nicht mehr so viele Sachen glauben musst, weil die ganze Welt ja die ganze Zeit auf dich,
einredet und dich von allem Möglichen überzeugen möchte und was du alles noch
glauben sollst, Gott und irgendwie Systeme Thema und Wirtschafts- und so weiter.
Ja, Regierungen, Politiker, das Richtige tun, all das und die Leute sind vollkommen überfordert.
Also nimmst du dir einen elektrischen Mönch, schaltest den da vor und dann hast
du Ruhe. Und vielleicht kommen wir jetzt so langsam in dieses Zeitalter des
elektrischen Mönchen. Wir lassen einfach die Bots irgendwie das machen.
Wir lehnen uns einfach zurück, die rennen dann die Welt und das wird schon alles passen.
Okay. Währenddessen kennzeichnen wir dann noch KI-generierte Inhalte.
Und YouTube sagt, du kannst ja nach Deepfakes suchen lassen.
Also versuchen sie an der Sache herum zu doktoren.
Ich glaube, das machen sie mit KI.
Aber wir brauchen natürlich auch nach all dieser lächerlichen Überschätzung
von KI und Linus und Tim sind auch in die KI-CoolAid gefallen und sloppen sich
jetzt da nur noch einen zurecht.
Müssen wir natürlich auch noch mal Witze machen über KI-Fates,
die uns zeigen, dass wir als Nerds immer noch auf unserer Kommandozeile die
Security richtig machen und alle mit ihrer AI Was können die denn schon?
Was können die denn schon?
Aber was war da los?
Meta?
Hat mal wieder ein paar tausend Leute entlassen und durch Karriere gesetzt.
Was ist überhaupt mit Meta? Also ich meine, der Laden, eigentlich heißt er ja
Facebook, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind.
Facebook, okay, also der Zuckerberg, der hat dann immer halt mal diese Nummer
durchgezogen, hat dann so in der Uni so sein privates Facebook,
da waren dann alle ganz heiß drauf, dann hat er das für die ganze Welt geöffnet
und ist irgendwie stinkereich damit geworden.
Dann hat er sich noch Instagram und WhatsApp dazu gekauft, um an der Stelle
nicht schnell überrollt zu werden. Das ist ihm ja auch ganz gut gelungen und
seitdem eiern die so ein bisschen rum.
Und jetzt probieren sie ja die ganze Zeit irgendwie auch Teil der Zukunft zu
sein. Da haben sie mal versucht, irgendwie Betriebssysteme zu bauen.
Dann wollten sie irgendwie, glaube ich, sogar mal Telefone bauen. Dann wollten sie,
mit 3D-Brillen und dann das Metaversum und so die Zukunft.
Haben sie jetzt auch langsam zugemacht?
Ja, das läuft alles nicht. Diese ganzen Zukunftsvorstellungen von Zuckerberg,
die verfangen einfach nicht.
Und so ist halt auch dieser ganze Laden völlig uninspiriert.
Weil sie so uninspiriert sind, Dann haben sie jetzt gesagt, naja,
jetzt sparen wir mal Geld und wir haben ja auch unser ERI-Modell.
Schalten wir das doch einfach mal in den Support. Übrigens etwas,
was wir überall sehen. Also ich rufe bei meiner ...
Auto-Werkstatt an und man hat irgendwie nur noch Karl den intelligenten Chatbot,
der dich nach allem ausfragt und wurde dann schon fast stolz auf dich,
bis dann nach zehn Minuten dann auch wirklich mal so einen Termin bekommen zu haben.
Andere verstecken sich in gewisser Hinsicht mehr dahinter. Jede Webseite hat so einen Quatsch.
Aber Meta hat es jetzt echt auf die Spitze getrieben und hat also wirklich einen,
AI-Support-Chatbot gebaut, der auch Zugriff hat auf alle Kundendaten.
Und dann sind einfach irgendwelche findigen Hacker in die Diskussion gegangen
und haben mit diesem Bot einfach ein bisschen diskutiert und gesagt so, ja,
ich bin hier, Name eines prominenten Instagram-Accounts und kannst mal meine
hinterlegte E-Mail ändern.
Und das System hat das dann getan. Also so einfach jetzt fremder Leute Accounts,
Hops zu nehmen, war es jetzt wirklich noch nie. Also was war da betroffen?
Obama, White House Account, ich weiß gar nicht, was noch alles.
Also ich bin das weiße Zuhause. Kannst du mal bitte meine E-Mail-Adresse ändern?
Das ist geil, oder?
Einfach Und dadurch, dass die E-Mail-Adresse geändert war, konnten sie danach
ein Passwort-Reset machen.
Genau, das ist dann sozusagen die Übernahme eines Accounts, einfach indem man
einfach mal die Maschine so ein bisschen bittet.
Insofern müssen wir uns vielleicht auch doch nicht so viele ganz so viele Sorgen
machen vor Skynet, weil wenn man Skynet einfach nur bittet, ganz freundlich
zu sein, nicht schießen, dann passt das schon.
Es gibt, also ja gut, Also...
Natürlich werden sich mit dieser ganzen Agentik-Nummer jetzt auch eine ganze
Reihe Leute richtig wunderschön in den Fuß schießen. Da kannst du dich ja auch richtig drauf freuen.
Und das ist auch das, was mir beruflich noch ein bisschen,
Hoffnung macht für die nächsten Jahre, weil da wird es noch genug,
Probleme zu lösen geben, die Leute sich selber machen, weil sie halt mal einen
Tag gevibe-coded haben und sich jetzt auf einmal für für irgendwie Grace Hopper
halten oder was auch immer.
Ja, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Und es ist schön, dass Facebook so blöd ist, aber Facebook, wie gesagt,
sind schon seit längerem, die waren eigentlich schon immer blöd.
Und insofern haben wir mal drüber gelacht.
Worüber nicht so viel gelacht wird oder wurde, ist der Referentenentwurf zum
Gesetz gegen digitale Gewalt.
Also das ist der Entwurf eines Gesetzes zur Stärkung des zivilrechtlichen und
strafrechtlichen Schutzes vor digitaler Gewalt.
Und das ist der Referentenentwurf, das heißt, der liegt noch im Ministerium, 16.
Und 17. April, wir hatten auch darüber gesprochen, dass er jetzt langsam in
der Öffentlichkeit präsentiert wurde, der ist aber noch nicht im parlamentarischen
Verfahren, das heißt, der ist jetzt noch nicht in den Bundestag herabgereicht worden,
sondern das sind jetzt die ersten Stellungnahmen, die die Verbände direkt an
das Justizministerium stellen.
Und.
Was will dieser Gesetzesentwurf alles regeln?
Einmal das gerichtliche Auskunftsverfahren,
also Diensteanbieter und Internetzugangsanbieter müssen auf richterliche Anordnung,
Bestand und Nutzungsdaten herausgeben, unter anderem Klarname,
Anschrift, IP-Adresse, Portnummer.
Aber damit die, und das geht mit Richterbeschluss über Landgericht,
also eine Person, ein Internetaccount kann mit einem Landgerichtsbeschluss deanonymisiert werden.
Wenn da IP-Adresse und Portnummer mit dazugehören, dann wisst ihr auch direkt,
es gibt damit einhergehend eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
vorsorglich gespeicherte Zuordnung von IP-Adresse.
Das ist verbunden mit einem parallelen Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetzentwurf.
Also weitgehende Eingriffe in die Pseudonymität und Anonymität im Internet generell,
und dann eben hier geregelt Auskunftsverfahren, um da auch darauf zugreifen zu können.
Dann gibt es eine Beweissicherungsanordnung, frühzeitige Sicherung von Daten.
Damit sie nicht bis zum Verfahrensende gelöscht werden können und damit auch
die Weitergabe an Strafverfolgungsbehörden,
die Möglichkeit einer Account-Sperre, wo also ein Richterin anordnen kann,
zeitweise einen Account zu sperren, und zwar bei schwerwiegenden Rechtsverletzungen
und Wiederholungsgefahr.
Und dann werden auch die Inhalte gelöscht. Und gleichzeitig aber natürlich Beweissicherungsanordnung.
Also wir sehen, da geht es dann, diese Aspekte gehören zusammen.
Dann natürlich, man braucht einen Zustellungsbevollmächtigen,
damit man diese Pflicht auch für Netzwerke mit Sitz außerhalb der EU durchsetzen kann.
Dann gibt es neue Straftatbestände. Der § 184 K StGB wird um Intimsphäre und Deepfakes erweitert.
Der § 201 B StGB, da geht es dann um täuschende Inhalte und Deepfakes.
Und dann soll ein neuer § 202 E StGB, da geht es dann um unbefugte digitale
Überwachung in dieser Stalking-Bereich.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hatte ich schon und.
Damit wären wir jetzt so,
bei den entscheidenden Aspekten. So, jetzt haben dazu mehrere Verbände Stellungnahmen
eingereicht, HateAid, der Deutsche Juristinnenbund,
Weiße Ring, Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und so weiter.
Ja, die Bundesrechtsanwaltinnenkammer, Strafverteidigervereinigung,
also da gibt es dann relativ viel.
Und ich will ein bisschen schauen, was die so,
dazu gesagt haben.
HateAid wird jetzt wenig verwundern, dass sie dem allen sehr positiv gegenüberstehen,
sich eher um Dauer der Verfahren sollen dann kürzer sein und so weiter.
Gerichtskosten sollen pauschal geregelt werden, weil es sonst natürlich das
rechtliche Risiko und so, das finanzielle Risiko des Vorgehens bleibt. Ja,
nicht überraschend. Dann gibt es natürlich andere Gruppierungen.
Die sich vielleicht ein bisschen auch mehr um die Grundrechtseinschnitte,
die da stattfinden, beschäftigen.
Zum Beispiel die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, die erstmal sagt,
okay, hier das mit den Accountsperren ist einfach ein
wirkungsvoller, positiver Mechanismus, vor allem, wenn er hier ein rechtsstaatlich
sauberes Verfahren hat und.
Der Inhaber oder die Inhaberin des betroffenen Accounts ja auch sich daran beteiligen
kann, dem entgegenwirken kann oder so.
Das heißt, da werden deren Rechte gewahrt und vor allem im Zweifelsfall ja diese
rechte Verletzung einer Person kann halt auch unmittelbar beendet werden.
Auch ist das natürlich ein ganz gut geeignetes, abschreckendes Damoklesschwert,
dass du siehst, okay, wenn ich mich jetzt hier, wenn ich jetzt weiter mich so
verhalte, dann wird mir dieser Account,
temporär oder dauerhaft gesperrt.
Das ist ja auch eine unmittelbare negative Konsequenz.
Dann sagen sie natürlich, was die GFF ablehnt, das ist auch sehr schön, dass sie die,
implizite Verbindung mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ablehnen,
die sich eben aus den Auskunftsansprüchen ergibt.
Dieser Auskunftsanspruch und das sind ja, das hatten wir glaube ich in einer
der vorherigen Sendungen schon besprochen, das sind ja auch Auskunftsansprüche
im zivilrechtlichen Verfahren. Das heißt nicht nur, ich erhebe,
was weiß ich, Strafantrag gegen,
die Person hinter diesem Account,
sondern ich will wissen, wer die Person hinter diesem Account ist.
Dann gab es etwas in diesem Bereich das Verbandsantragsrecht,
wo es darum geht, dass du nicht eine individuell betroffene Person brauchst,
bei gruppenbezogener digitaler Gewalt.
Also beispielsweise Antisemitismus. Da musst du jetzt nicht eine individuelle
beleidigte Person finden oder verletzte oder angegriffene Person,
sondern du kannst mit einem Verband direkt dagegen vorgehen.
Und da sagt die GfF, das kann man eigentlich ruhig drin lassen, damit du,
nicht die Beschwerdelast immer auf Individuen hast.
Digital Courage, natürlich und auch wichtig und richtig starke Kritik an dieser
Idee der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Massenüberwachung, müssen nochmal klar betonen,
das wird ja dann von allen gespeichert.
Also nicht nur von, also es wird von jedem Account, jeder einzelnen Person gespeichert
und wenn diese Daten einmal gespeichert werden, dann wird der Zugriff darauf
immer nur weiter ausgeweitet.
Und übrigens haben sich auch andere ExpertInnen im Themenbereich digitale Gewalt
gegen Überwachungsmaßnahmen ausgesprochen,
zu denen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zählt, weil es geht ja vor allem darum,
das Phänomen zu stoppen und den Menschen eine schnelle Abhilfe,
zu schaffen, wo eben die GFF ja diese Account sperren.
Und ich meine sogar, mich zu erinnern, dass das eigentlich ein Vorschlag von
der GFF schon vor vielen Jahren war.
Das heißt, da wurde auch im Prinzip eine Idee, die sie schon länger versuchen
in die Diskussion einzubringen, aufgenommen.
Die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer findet natürlich den Auskunftsanspruch und die,
Sicherungsanordnung im Zivilrecht grundsätzlich sinnvoll.
Klar, da können die natürlich dann schön neue Verfahren mitführen.
Aber sie sagen, die Anforderungen an die gerichtliche Prüfung sind zu hoch.
Es sollte eine glaubhaft gemachte mögliche Rechtsverletzung genügen,
nicht deren Feststellung.
Mit anderen Worten, die sagen dann halt, komm, dieser Auskunftsanspruch,
der muss einfach hier, wir wollen nie im Zweifel haben, an wen wir hier verklagen wollen oder so.
Lehnen gleichzeitig aber die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ab ich,
denke nun ja also da stimme ich Ihnen zu bei der Accountsperre finden Sie die Schwelle zu niedrig,
Sie denken dass es halt zu viel,
also dass es dann zu einem inflationären Gebrauch,
führen könnte, dieser Accountsperren.
Und damit dann halt ein Risiko für die Meinungsfreiheit entsteht,
wenn einfach die ganzen Leute sich gegenseitig, wenn sie sich einmal im Internet
zanken, die Accounts sperren lassen.
Und sie haben dann noch, und da kommen wir jetzt auf dieses juristische Terrain,
wo es dann irgendwie um die Deepfakes, Deepfake-Kriminalisierung,
da haben sie dann im Detail,
kritisieren sie die Formulierung, da würde ich lieber nochmal in Ruhe mit Leuten
drüber reden, die sich in dem Phänomenbereich besser auskennen und vor allem
in dem juristischen Kontext, in dem dieser Absatz steht.
Aber, ja, Datenweitergabe, das ist schon alle, also,
es werden halt hier, sind hier halt
so ein paar Überwachungsmaßnahmen und Grundrechtseingriffe drin, die halt,
wo ich nicht der Einzige bin, die halt so ein bisschen sagen,
das scheint vielleicht ein bisschen auch themengebietsfremd zu sein.
Trotzdem bei allen, da schließe ich mich ein, breiter Konsens über das Ziel,
besserer Schutz der Betroffenen,
und natürlich auch ein strafrechtlicher Handlungsbedarf bei bildbasierter sexualisierter
Gewalt, insbesondere eben Deepfakes, hatten wir auch vor mehreren Sendungen
schon drüber gesprochen.
Das ist halt nicht witzig und das ist eine schwerwiegende Herabwürdigung,
vor allem wenn das irgendwie besonders sexualisierte Deepfakes sind.
Entsprechend, das finden alle gut. Vorratsdatenspeicherung lehnen viele ab,
die Strafverteidiger, Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer, GFF, Digital Courage, HateAid.
Eher akzeptieren das so, scheinen auch so ungefähr die Einzigen zu sein,
was aber eben auch mit ihrem Hintergrund jetzt verständlich ist,
ja, aber deswegen gibt es eben auch die anderen, die halt ein bisschen breitere Kontexte haben.
Die Account-Sperre,
eigentlich auch begrüßt von betroffenen Seite.
Die GFF lobt die Verfahrensrechte, die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer sagt,
das ist eher ein bisschen zu niedrig.
Die Strafverteidiger sagen, das ist Vorverurteilung und Beweisvernichtung weil
ja gelöscht werden soll aber da würde ich insgesamt sagen, also auch ein halbwegs.
Das klingt nach etwas, über das man sich einigen kann,
das Verbandantragsrecht das hätten gerne viele drin gehabt.
Nur die Bundesrechtsanwaltkammer sagt, Vertretung durch Organisationen bei höchstpersönlichen
Ansprüchen ist das systemwidrig. Also die wollen natürlich lieber selber das
machen statt einer Organisation. Ähm,
In diesen tatsächlichen Strafrechtsparagrafen teilweise Forderungen über die,
Formulierung, Nachschärfung der Formulierungen und dann diskutieren sie darüber,
ob allein schon die Herstellung eines Deepfakes,
also wo ist quasi die Schwelle zur Strafe.
Die Herstellung selber oder die Verbreitung.
Da kann man natürlich jetzt auch noch ins Detail gehen.
Sicherlich ist die Verbreitung irgendwo ein bisschen zu spät und die Herstellung
hat halt das Risiko, zu früh zu sein, um halt relativ viele vielleicht in irgendeiner Form,
realistische oder,
legitime Anwendungsfälle zu finden. mit in die Definition zu ziehen.
So stelle ich mir diese Diskussion vor, müsste man sich,
nochmal detaillierter anschauen mit Leuten, die mehr von dem Phänomenbereich
verstehen. Deswegen habe ich jetzt
mal mich eher auf die technischen und netzpolitischen Aspekte fokussiert.
Tja, Mensch, vielleicht nur AI-Fragen, was man da tun kann.
Also das mit den Deepfacts ist natürlich schon so ein...
Also ich meine, ganz einig sind wir uns wahrscheinlich darüber, dass das da,
wenn Grog auf Twitter sogar direkt quasi auf Unterposts von Leuten drunter antwortet,
dass da irgendwie der Bereich ist, den will man sicherlich nicht haben. Und,
Ich wäre schon eigentlich an der Stelle, also meine laienhafte Einschätzung,
der Situation ist, dass man einfach die Hersteller halt auch dafür haftbar machen
sollte, wenn sie sowas erstellen.
Und das könnte wahrscheinlich schon relativ viel klären, dass sie das dann nicht
mehr anbieten oder eben sehr große Vorkehrungen,
machen, dass sie aus dem Haftungsrisiko kommen. Beispielsweise dadurch, dass sie halt,
die Legitimität der Herstellung stark prüfen oder es einfach komplett sein lassen,
oder eben sicherstellen, dass sie Menschen, die bestimmte Systeme rechtswidrig
verwenden, auch ans Messer liefern können.
Ja.
Ansonsten haben wir, es gibt ja von Netzpolitik.org diese, ja schon jetzt relativ
lange, diese Recherche zu den Data Brokern, also dass sie sich quasi,
diese ganzen Datensammlungen aus der,
eigentlich aus dieser Werbetracking, hast du nicht gesehen, alles,
was jetzt so, gibt man Testdatensatz oder so,
dass sie dazu viel forschen und veröffentlichen und jetzt haben sie halt festgestellt,
dass es bei der Polizei auch verwendet wird, dass die Polizei halt diese,
ich denke eigentlich relativ klar rechtswidrigen Datensammlungen prüft,
äh nutzt, ja, statt dagegen vorzugehen ist dann die Polizei der Kunde.
Wundert mich jetzt auch wiederum nicht, aber also,
macht auch keinen Spaß.
Ja, Daten sind, wenn sie einfach da sind, werden sie auch genutzt.
Das ist einfach die Realität.
Ja, aber es gibt ja in der Funfacts-Folge, da ist ja eher so spaßeshalber auch über die,
hier über diese Gesichtersuchmaschinen gesagt. Komplett illegal und deswegen
so beliebt bei der Polizei. Ja, weil, so ist es halt auch bei den Data Brokers, also,
Mann.
Wenn sich die Polizei wenigstens an die Gesetze halten würde.
Ein bisschen viel verlangt, oder?
So, wir kommen zum Ende, denn Ende Gelände ist auch für DE-Mail.
Wie lange ist dein vernichtender Talk her jetzt?
30 C3 oder so?
Tja, gucken wir mal.
Nee, oder war der frühen?
Wie hieß er noch gleich so schön? Die E-Mail.
Bullshit made in Germany.
Das war, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, also 39 oder 30.
30C3 tatsächlich. Und der 30C3, das kann man heutzutage nicht mehr so richtig zurückrechnen.
Also das ist hier veröffentlicht worden.
Das ist 13 Jahre her, oder? oder? Ja.
Warte mal, das ist hier nicht der Originalpost. Also gehen wir mal auf die 2013.
Ja, 13 Jahre. Also drei Kongresse sind ausgefallen. Wir sind dieses Jahr bei
40. Ach, weiß der geil, kann ich auch nicht ausrechnen, so eine KI.
Ist aber auf jeden Fall so. 2013.
Ja, das war auch wirklich, also das war so lächerlich.
Dass wir 15 Jahre Wovon reden wir überhaupt?
Wovon reden wir überhaupt? Die Jüngeren wissen wieder nicht Bescheid.
Also, was sie...
Das ist ja auch, also, ach, herrje.
Es war einmal eine deutsche Bundesregierung.
Es war einmal eine deutsche Bundesregierung. Die wollte halt sagen,
wir möchten mit dem, wir möchten, dass der rechtsverbindliche Verkehr,
Schriftverkehr, ist auch schon der rechtsverbindliche Schriftverkehr,
sich über das Internet abbilden kann.
So, dafür, wenn jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, hannohase.web.de dir eine E-Mail
schreibt, dann kann natürlich ein Gericht jetzt nicht sagen,
okay, wir akzeptieren, dass das von dem ist.
Oder nachvollziehbar.
Das ist erstmal in Ordnung. Und jetzt hätte man natürlich unterschiedlichste
technische Verfahren haben können, was weiß ich, qualifizierte elektronische
Signatur mit einem Personalausweis.
Es war damals auch problemlos möglich, hätte es alles gegeben,
aber sie wollten, haben gesagt, okay, wir brauchen jetzt mal irgendwie so ein seriöses System.
Wo vor allem dann nämlich auch, das war eines der großen Risiken,
warum ich mir niemals so eine D-Mail-Adresse geholt habe, wo du eben auch dieses
Zustellungsbeleg hast.
Ja, wenn du nämlich, also wenn du dich jetzt in einer rechtlichen Auseinandersetzung,
befindest, dann kommen immer diese schönen gelben Umschläge,
wo Einschreiben persönlich oder Einschreiben Einwurf oder sowas draufsteht,
damit dir das rechtssicher zugestellt wurde.
Und die rechtssichere Zustellung ist in vielen juristischen Verfahren natürlich
aus gutem Grund geschehen.
Ein relevanter Faktor. Das geht so weit, dass bestimmte Verfahren nicht geführt werden oder,
Vorgänge nicht abgeschlossen werden können, weil man die Betroffenen nicht rechtsverbindlich,
oder rechtsgültig darüber informieren kann.
Da haben die dann teilweise, ich kenne mich da nicht so aus,
aber dann kann man das aushängen. Dann wird das am Gericht ausgehängt, um dem Genüge zu tun.
Aber die Zustellung ist halt entscheidend und das war dann, dann definieren
wir jetzt eben ein System, was wir dann,
in den Gesetzen als weitere Möglichkeit der rechtssicheren Kommunikation definieren.
Und zwar in der Kommunikation,
mit den Behörden und auch in der Kommunikation mit den Gerichten.
Das war dann das E-Government- und das E-Justice-Gesetz.
Und dieses technische System hatten sie vorher sich schon definieren lassen. Das war die D-Mail.
E-Mail, D-E-Mail.
D-E-Mail.
Schickste, ne?
Ja.
Und dann haben sie halt dieses Quatschsystem da formuliert. Das war eigentlich
auch nur E-Mail mit marginalen Abwanderungen.
Da habe ich halt einen Vortrag drüber gehalten, weil ich dann,
die Sicherheit dieses Systems,
die Architektur dieses Systems und die,
entsprechende Anwendungen im E-Justice und E-Government-Gesetz dann da mal beurteilt
hatte als Sachverständiger. Und das war natürlich haarsträubend.
Das war einfach absoluter Käse.
Und entsprechend habe ich das auch in dem Vortrag vertreten.
Ja.
War ganz witzig damals. Und dann haben halt auch nur wenige mitgemacht.
Also ich glaube hier Gmx1 und1, die hatten da den D-Mail-Server.
Die wollten schnell dabei sein.
Die Deutsche Telekom hatte das auch. Dann haben sie das irgendwie gepusht wie Hulle.
Und eigentlich von all diesen Leuten, ich kannte diese D-Mail-Betreiber ja auch,
haben dann in der vorgehaltenen Hand dann auch erzählt, dass da irgendwie eine hohe,
einstellige Anzahl D-Mails am Tag über diesen Server rasselt.
Da war also, das hat jetzt einfach keine Sau benutzt.
Natürlich nicht. absoluter Käse. Dann haben sie es irgendwann versucht,
dir irgendwie runterzuzwingen, den Rachen, also irgendwie einen 50-Euro Zalando-Gutschein
oder so einen Scheiß bekommen. Also das...
Und aber es hat halt keine Sau.
Und ja, also das sollte dann eben, ich glaube, seit 2024 ist die Bundesverwaltung
nicht mehr zur Nutzung verpflichtet.
Die Deutsche Telekom hat dann einfach die Verluste bremsen wollen,
hat sie irgendwie schon eingestellt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche D-Mail-Anbieter es noch gibt.
Aber da haben dann auch wieder was da für Consulting-Buden geschrieben.
Ach, herrje, meine Güte.
Und jetzt wird es einfach eingestellt.
Ja, aber das war halt auch wirklich, wenn ich mal so viele Jahre später zurückblicke,
das war genauso half-assed wie die elektronische Patientenakte.
Weißt du, das sind einfach so stümperhafte Sachen.
Kaputt konsultete Hirngespinste von irgendwelchen von irgendwelchen Phantasten,
die keine Ahnung haben und irgendwelchen Quatschreden und dann,
es ist halt dramatisch.
Dramatisch. Mit KI wird das alles besser.
Wahrscheinlich wirklich, wenn man richtig promptet allerdings auch nur.
Wenn ich die richtigen Fragen frage, dann wird er auch keine guten Ergebnisse bekommen.
Politiker prompten dann halt ich will das, das muss sicher sein.
Ja, also es ist immer wieder dieselbe Geschichte und es ist halt einfach ein
Ergebnis dieses fortwährenden.
Wie soll man das sagen, so ein,
Maschinenstürmer, Don Quixote-Appeal, man muss sich immer erst mal gegen alles wehren.
Also als das ganze Internet aufkam in den 90er Jahren, das hast du ja auch noch
mitbekommen, wie dann sofort diese Abwehrhaltung erst mal hochging mit,
ach dieses ganze neue Zeug mit dem Internet, das brauchen wir alles gar nicht,
ich lese ja hier ein Buch, das ist ja viel schöner, ich gehe ja in den Wald und so.
Die Argumente finden wir auch heute noch in den Kommentaren,
wenn es um AI geht im Übrigen, aber das kam halt schon sehr früh.
Es war halt sofort so diese Ablehnung, ach das kennen wir nicht,
das kann gar nicht relevant sein.
Dann war es irgendwann so groß und dann hat die ganze Wirtschaft danach geschrien.
Dann wurde natürlich wieder gleich in jedem Dorf das nächste Silicon Valley
ausgerufen und irgendwo Geld reingeworfen.
Ja, und da ging natürlich dann auch nichts.
Dann kamen irgendwie die Jahr 2000 Startup-Bubble-Platze.
Dann waren wieder alle ganz frustriert. Aber es hat sich halt einfach niemals
irgendwie in irgendeiner Form mal so eine natürliche Annäherung an diese Technologie
und seine Gegebenheiten ergeben.
Sondern man hat dann immer erst reagiert, wenn man gemerkt hat,
jetzt reden aber alle davon, jetzt müssen wir das auch machen.
Und dann ohne Erfahrung und ohne Gefühl für diese Technologien.
Das ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem.
Erst lehnt man alles ab, man beteiligt sich an gar nichts und vor allem.
Und dann will man was eigenes haben und baut eine 80er Jahre Schrottechnologie nochmal neu.
Genau, weil das ist irgendwie das Einzige, was man auch irgendwie kennt.
Was man kennt. Weil man sich mit dem neuen Kram so nicht auseinandergesetzt hat.
Und ja, dann bedient sich das halt auch alles wie so ein DOS-Programm.
Und das ist halt auch immer noch nicht da. Also wir haben immer noch nicht diese Ausprobierkultur.
In China, da wird dann einfach gesagt so, ja, hier neue Gelegenheiten,
probiert mal alles aus, wir suchen uns mal das Beste raus.
Und wir hatten mal so ein Glimmer of Hope, weißt du noch, als es irgendwie mit
Corona losging und dann irgendwie Corona-Warned.
Glimmer of Hope.
Ja, und wir bringen jetzt mal alle an den Tisch und wir machen mal hier so einen Hackathon.
Das war so der einzige Moment, wo ich mal wirklich so das Gefühl hatte,
jetzt wachen sie mal auf und jetzt nähern wir uns mal so einem natürlichen Prozess
an und jetzt streuen wir einfach mal die Intelligenz, die ja da ist.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt niemand in der Lage wäre, gute Technologie hervorzubringen in Deutschland.
Sondern es ist einfach nur, dass es von der Politik immer ignoriert wurde,
es kein Vertrauen gibt in so ein dynamisches Ausprobieren und da komme ich immer
wieder auf diesen Punkt zurück.
Da bin ich einfach wirklich, ich bin ja sonst wirklich ein Optimist,
aber was Deutschland betrifft bin ich wirklich pessimistisch geworden,
weil es einfach auch in der gesamten Gesellschaft immer diese Widerstände gibt.
Es darf sich nichts ändern, es ist ja eigentlich alles ganz gut, das reicht doch schon.
Wir sind doch irgendwie, was weiß ich, Exportweltmeister und Autofabrikant Nummer
eins und deutsche Qualität und made in Germany und was man sich nicht hier alles
drauf einbildet und der Rest der Welt lacht sich einfach schlapp.
Mittlerweile sind wir wirklich zu so einem Laughingstock geworden.
Da ist das mit dem Wal wirklich jetzt nur so die Sahne obendrauf noch.
Das Land, was die Solarenergiewirtschaft erfunden hat und dann einfach so freiwillig über Bord geworfen hat.
Ach, macht ihr das doch mal mit der Zukunft.
Es ist einfach nur traurig und es ist einfach zum Heulen und deswegen passieren
solche Sachen. Und die E-Mail und irgendwie Gesundheitspatientenakte,
das ist alles so stümperhaft.
Und ich meine, wie lange ist unser Digitalminister jetzt im Amt?
Ein Jahr, was haben wir denn jetzt? Wie lange haben wir denn schon diese neue
Regierung? Etwas über ein Jahr. Ja, okay. Also in gewisser Hinsicht ist er ja noch Welpenschutz.
Ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass er innerhalb von zwei Jahren irgendwas
nennen, soweit es dabei rauskommen kann. Dann allerdings müsste ja eigentlich mal was passieren.
Allein mir fehlt der Glaube. Also ich habe da jetzt auch bisher noch nichts,
gehört, was in irgendeiner Form mal ein Umdenken triggert.
Von daher werden wir hier wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile was zu erzählen haben.
Der Fehler, also das ist halt ein,
also was du in all diesen Dingen siehst, ist, dass die Sachen halt nicht zu Ende gedacht werden.
Weißt du, wenn du, also Beispiel digitale Patientenakte.
Patientenakten sind eh eine Albtraum, alles irgendwelche Briefe,
das ist ja wirklich die Definition von vollständig unstrukturierten Durcheinanderdaten.
Das ist ja jetzt keine Daten.
Das ist eine Akte. Es sind halt keine Daten. Und wenn du eine.
Sagst, du möchtest eine Patientenakte haben, die ÄrztInnen dabei unterstützt,
einen schnellen Überblick zu bekommen über ihre Patientin,
dann kannst du natürlich oder bräuchtest du natürlich etwas,
was im Prinzip ein Datenmodell darstellt,
was eine Einheitlichkeit abbildet, damit du davon profitieren kannst,
dass es jetzt eine Datensammlung gibt.
Damit auch die Verständlichkeit für die Person, die diese Patientenakte konsumieren
muss, erhöht ist im Vergleich zu einer scheiß Akte.
Und das ist, ich habe gerade immer gesagt, Leute wollen keine Powerpoints,
sondern die wollen eine Präsentation.
Und ein Patient will keine Akte oder ein Ärztin will auch keine Akte,
sondern eine Information. Nur Deutsche.
Die wollen wirklich Akten. Da ist die Akte Selbstzweck.
Und dann wird das so gemacht. Und dann hast du dieses, dann wird da mal so ein
digitaler Leuchtturm gemacht.
Dann wird nämlich eine Mittelalter-Technologie oder eine vorindustrielle Technologie,
die Akte, die heben wir jetzt in das digitale Zeitalter.
Nein, die Idee ist, dass wir das neue Medium nutzen und eben nicht jetzt wieder
eine Akte, sondern wir machen jetzt mal ein System.
Und dann gehen irgendwelche, wenn du jetzt dann die Digitalisierung der Verwaltung
anschaust, meine Güte, so kompliziert kann die ja gar nicht sein,
als dass du jetzt nicht mal ein paar Abläufe da drin digital abbilden könntest.
Aber dann geht jedes Land einzeln hin und baut einen Leuchtturm neben dem anderen.
Und diese D-Mail war halt auch so ein Leuchtturm. Dann konntest du von dem einen
Leuchtturm zu dem anderen eine D-Mail schicken.
Und dann wunderst du dich, dass das nicht irgendwie abgeht.
Es ist mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass man das sowieso alles auf europäischer
Ebene jetzt lösen müsste, weil jetzt irgendwie deutsche Lösungen fragt eh kein Mensch.
Ja, das ist, das ist, ja.
Und wenn du dir, wenn du dir anschaust, dann haben sie den, den Abend,
das war übrigens, das kann ich ja heute,
sagen, da kam ja dann auch nachher dann, als die mit dem besonderen elektronischen
Anwaltspostfach anfingen, da kam ja dann auch die,
Verbände der Anwältinnen zu mir und sagten so,
scheiße, wir haben gesehen, was die da mit der D-Mail gemacht haben, so.
Und jetzt wollen die uns hier so ein Anwaltspostfach reinbürgen,
weil das mit der Demel nicht läuft und so und jetzt haben wir die Scheiße am
Schuh und haben sie ja auch, wenn du dir das anguckst, ich hab mir da irgendwie
dieses Besondere, dieses Bär angeguckt,
ich mein, wenn dein Produkt schon besonders heißt, ich mein,
das ist doch, da weißt du doch Bescheid.
Das sagt man doch auch schon im Kindergarten nur zu den Fisch.
Also das ist, Zu ganz besonderen Dingen sagt man das nur.
Und wenn das schon im Titel ist, das ist besonders. Oh, scheiße.
Ja. Deutschland das Sorgenkind.
In diesem Kontext gibt es übrigens ähm,
Die Deutschland-App hast du ja mitbekommen.
Was? Habe ich mitbekommen?
Ja, das ist etwas, das hatten wir hier so ein bisschen außen vor gelassen.
Können wir mal noch ein Thema gerade draus machen? Die Deutschland-App.
Also, das wird die zentrale Bürger-App, die Behördengänge, Anträge und staatliche
Dienstleistungen auf einer einzigen KI-gestützten Plattform bündeln soll.
Wird von Telekom und SAP entwickelt, weil du nämlich meintest,
was macht der Wildberger?
Und du musst dir, also was verbirgt sich hinter dieser Idee,
KI-gestützte Plattform?
Die, also wenn du jetzt mal die Situation vorstellst, wie sie sich jetzt der
deutschen Bürgerin gerade bietet, wenn die jetzt zu einer Behörde will,
gibt x Behörden und von den meisten gibt es sogar 16 unterschiedliche,
weil wir 16 Bundesländer haben.
Was weiß ich, Beantragung von Sozialleistung, Wohnsitz ummelden,
was weiß ich, neuen Führerschein beantragen.
Ich weiß auch immer nicht, wo ich da in Berlin jetzt gerade hin muss oder so. Und,
Gefängnis und was nicht alles. Also es gibt ja Unmengen an Behörden,
mit denen du interfacen musst und einige davon sind dann Bundesbehörden,
einige sind Landesbehörden und das ist ja ein unüberschaubarer Dschungel.
Und was diese Deutschland-App jetzt macht, ist, die gehen quasi hin und suchen,
sich diese APIs zusammen und diese Formulare und diese Prozesse,
und diese trainieren dann quasi eine KI darauf, damit umzugehen,
um dann eine App zu machen,
damit die Bürgerin eine App hat und sagt,
Heute will ich Bürgergeld in Hessen beantragen und morgen meinen Wohnsitz in Bayern,
ummelden. Und das kann dann alles diese App. Aber damit sie diese Vereinheitlichung,
sie haben quasi die Idee aufgegeben,
einfach mal eine einheitliche, vernünftige Plattform zu bauen,
sondern sie stülpen da jetzt einfach ein zentrales Frontend vor,
was mit einer KI dann dabei hilft, das zu machen und so verrückt es klingt.
Ist es wahrscheinlich die einzige Lösung, über diesen Scheiß,
noch ein Interface drüber zu stülpen, mit dem irgendwann nochmal ein Mensch arbeiten kann.
Also mir würde, also so absurd das einerseits ist, zeigt es halt auch die Hilflosigkeit,
und die Komplexität und das Desaster, in das wir uns da jetzt gefahren haben.
Vergiss nicht, Behörde ist auch, du machst deine Wohnsitzummeldung in irgendeiner Kleinstadt.
Die hat ja dann auch wieder irgendeine, vielleicht bietet die einen digitalen
Prozess an, vielleicht auch nicht.
Muss man auf der Webseite gucken. Wenn du Glück hast, kommst du nicht auf irgendeine Phishing-Seite.
Also,
das ist ohne Sinn und Verstand über Jahrzehnte gebastelt worden. Von irgendwelchen,
Leuten, die eigentlich lieber eine Akte gehabt hätten. Das ist,
ja.
Also diese Deutschland-App ist vom Auswärtigen Amt?
Nee. Nein, das ist vom Digitalministerium.
Okay, aber es gibt eine.
Also das ist eine Idee. Und nochmal, das ist von einer, also,
man kann ja jetzt viel, man kann an tausend Dingen natürlich und KI-App und so weiter.
Das Entscheidende ist, ähm,
Dass es digitale Angebote da draußen gibt, die dir einen Behördengang ersparen können.
Die nutzt aber natürlich keiner,
weil die alle scheiße sind und alle unterschiedlich und alle heterogen.
Und weiß der Geier, es gibt 16 Bundesländer, so und so viele Behörden,
so und so viele Prozesse, die du da abbilden kannst.
Und die Deutschland-App ist im Prinzip zu sagen, okay, wir versuchen das mal mit KI zu sortieren,
um letztendlich diese komischen Web 1.0-Formulare,
die diese unterschiedlichen Verwaltungen irgendwo in diesem Internet bereitstellen,
den Bürgerinnen zugänglich zu machen.
Und nochmal, ich finde das sogar, ich finde das von der Idee,
also ich wüsste auch nicht, wie ich es anders machen sollte.
Also in der aktuellen Situation, wo eben nichts einheitlich ist,
jeder seinen eigenen Scheiß macht und die meisten Sachen völlig unbenutzbar
sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft du schon an Berlin.de verzweifelt bist.
Ja, da will man irgendeinen Behördengang machen und immerhin gibt es ja jetzt
Termine neuerdings. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mitbekommen hast.
Man kriegt jetzt kurzfristig Termine. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das hinbekommen haben.
Man kriegt nur kurzfristig Termine.
Nee, es gibt jetzt so Termine, Termine. Das Problem ist nur dann erstmal die
richtige Art von Terminen zu finden.
Dann hast du da so eine kilometerlange Liste von so Amtsbezeichnungen,
was da angeblich getan werden soll, die alle vollkommen unverständlich sind.
Und da wäre in der Tat ein Chatbot ein ganz gutes Interface.
Das kann aber natürlich nicht dauerhaft die Lösung sein. vor allem eben nicht,
wenn du wirklich akkurate Informationen haben willst.
Diese App ist, also diese, also die Vision dieser App ist,
Ja, letztendlich, also ich weiß nicht, ob das Interface dann ein Chatbot ist,
aber dass du sagst, ich will folgendes tun und dass du dir dann die richtigen Fragen stellst.
Nehmen wir beispielsweise Formulare füllen. Also was du jetzt,
nochmal, bisher ist diese App nur eine Idee, aber ich stelle mir die jetzt mal in gut vor.
Was jetzt, das wird so nicht sein.
Ist ja klar, die wird scheiße, aber die Idee, also mal angenommen,
du könntest jetzt entweder auf berlin.de sagen, was weiß ich,
ich brauche einen neuen Parkausweis für Anwohnerparken oder so weiter.
Und dann klickst du dich da eine Dreiviertelstunde durch oder du machst halt
irgendeine App auf, die sagt, welchen Behördengang wollen wir heute erledigen?
Und dann sagt die App zum Beispiel, naja, pass auf, brauchst du folgende Sachen,
hasse, mach mal mach mal bitte ein Foto von deinem Führerschein,
Fahrzeugpapiere oder was auch immer du da hochladen musst.
Und kann ja dann zum Beispiel die Dokumente validieren und sagt dir,
hör mal, pass auf, der Perso ist abgelaufen oder zum Beispiel,
ey, Vorsicht, ich würde den Behördengang nicht machen, gib,
eine Fahndung nach dir oder so.
Können ja schöne Features sein.
Und dann könnte die App zum Beispiel auch sagen, okay, leg mal schon mal alles
zusammen. Ich sage, hast du die Information? Nein.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt schon mal weiter. Holen wir schon mal die anderen ein.
Wir brauchen noch die Kindergarten-Meldung deines Erstgeborenen oder so weiter.
Und da könnte man natürlich gerade mit der Flexibilität, die ja so eine KI-Interface
bietet, sicherlich eine ganz nette...
Nutzungserfahrung bereitstellen. Vor allem, wenn du dir vorstellst,
dass Berlin ja ein relativ kleines Bundesland ist und,
in dem Teil reden wir sogar von einer Stadt und wenn du das jetzt mal multiplizierst
mit dem Estate da draußen,
finde ich die Vision, eine angenehme User Experience an einem zentralen Punkt
zu bauen, kann ich mir nur vorstellen, dass es mit so einer KI gehen könnte.
Das heißt nicht, dass sie das hinkriegen, aber zumindest als Ansatz,
fällt mir kein anderer ein.
Nochmal, im Angesicht von zwei Jahrzehnten,
Verkackungen mit Anlauf,
ist das jetzt das Einzige, was der neue auskommen,
kann.
Hoffen wir das Beste, wir werden das begleiten. Ich war gerade ein bisschen
verwirrt, weil das Auswärtige Amt hat auch eine Deutschland,
ein Deutschland.de App, Wo aber nur schöne Nachrichten über Deutschland sind.
Wundert mich nicht, dass irgendeine andere Behörde schon eine hat.
Ja, genau.
Wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Wir können nur hoffen, dass der Krieg in der Ukraine bald vorbei ist.
Sodass die auch mal Zeit haben, sich um was anderes zu kümmern.
Weil die haben ja diese ganzen Probleme schon gelöst.
Oder einfach Estland mal machen lassen. Die haben, also okay,
E-Voting bin ich jetzt nicht so dafür. Aber ansonsten haben die das mit der,
Automatisierung des Startes schon ganz gut hinbekommen. Das Problem ist nur...
Und das ist ja auch ein Grund, warum diese Software so scheiße ist,
ist, weil die Realität, die du da abbilden willst, die ist ja auch schon so bizarr.
Also es ist einfach diese Struktur des Staates ist einfach so broken,
diese Ineffizienzen, die sich dann in diesen Webseiten widerspiegeln,
die reflektieren ja nur, was tatsächlich an Verhärmungen, an struktureller Verhärmung,
in diesem Land fest drin steckt und sich nicht lösen lässt.
Und eigentlich, wenn man, angenommen, wir werden.
Jetzt so die Berater, Deutschland ruft an, ey Linus, in Deutschland ist am Telefon,
die wollen, dass wir mal vorbeikommen, okay, lass mal machen.
Dann gehen wir da so hin und dann erzählen die so, was sie für ein Problem haben,
was sie gelöst haben wollen. Und wir hören uns das so fünf Stunden lang an,
gucken uns das dann irgendwie an und sagen so, also, ich glaube,
das muss man erstmal so auf einer strukturellen Ebene lösen.
Da kommt man jetzt so mit Software nicht bei, wenn das alles so uneinheitlich
ist. Also würde ich erst mal die Prozesse vereinfachen, dann erklärt sich das
in gewisser Hinsicht auch von selber.
Und dann Deutschland so, ja nee, also das geht nicht.
Ja wieso nicht? Naja, das geht nicht.
Das sind alle dagegen.
Haben wir schon immer so gemacht.
Haben wir schon immer so gemacht und das kriegen wir nicht durchgesetzt und
überhaupt. Das ist nicht populär.
Ja und das ist wirklich, und nochmal, weil ich jetzt schon die Kommentare sehe.
Das ist natürlich, wird das alles irgendwie wild und diese Deutschland-App,
darfst du nicht vergessen, wenn du so einen Behördengang machst,
musst du dich ja auch irgendwie ausweisen. Das heißt, da bist du dann halt Eudi-Wallet-nah.
Dann haben wir den ganzen Kram, über den wir mit Thomas gesprochen haben.
Es geht gerade mir nur um, wirklich und zwar spezifisch nur,
um diesen einen Aspekt User-Interface und Prozesse.
Und dann haben wir einen solchen Zoo, dass es absolut naheliegend ist,
dass man den nicht mehr gebändigt kriegt, sondern dass man einfach sagt,
da machen wir einen Abstraktionslayer drüber.
Aber wir versuchen, wir gucken, ob wir eine KI darauf trainiert kriegen.
Wir versuchen dazu zu ergründen, diesen absoluten Unsinn da irgendwie abzubilden,
und dann halt wegzuabstrahieren und dann klimpert da eine KI drauf.
Also das wäre zumindest, muss ich auch sagen, wenn man an diesem Klumpatsch
festhält und den nicht alles abreißt, dann würde mir auch nichts anderes einfallen,
dass es nie so weit hätte kommen dürfen,
Ist richtig. Darüber haben wir gerade gesprochen. Also es hätte nie so weit
kommen dürfen, aber jetzt haben wir den Salat.
Und das Ausmaß des Salates zeigt sich daran, dass man da jetzt,
dass man nur noch sagt, wir gehen da mit einer K.I. drüber. Was soll ich dazu noch sagen?
Deutschland Salat. Shit, genau, mal Deutschland Salat.
Ich weiß nicht,
du findest ja Estland so toll.
Das habe ich so nicht gesagt. Ich habe nur gesagt, die kriegen das hin.
Ja, ich glaube, da war irgendwie kürzlich so ein Datenreichtum in einem dieser Digitalländer.
Ja, mit Sicherheit. Also ich sage nicht, die sind unfehlbar oder so,
aber die haben zumindest, also die baltischen Länder, die waren ja quasi,
in dieser Situation, als sie sich dann eben final von Russland abgespalten haben, dass sie,
daraus wieder befreit wurden vielmehr,
dass sie ja dann schnell in die EU wollten und einfach Reform,
Reform, Reform durchgezogen haben und dabei einfach das Digitale einfach schon mitgedacht haben.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ein Vorteil, dass du quasi jetzt genau in dem Moment,
wo so ein technologischer Bruch ohnehin,
stattfindet, dass du dann eben oder in dem Moment, wo du so einen Staatsbruch
hast, auch noch gleich den technologischen Bruch mitziehen kannst.
Also insofern perfektes Timing.
Aber natürlich auch die Bereitschaft der Gesellschaft, hier neue Wege zu gehen
und dann wussten sie, wir müssen irgendwie effizient sein.
In dieser Situation ist Deutschland nicht. In dieser Situation bist du eigentlich
nur, wenn du ohnehin in irgendeiner Form eine externe Disruption hattest.
Wie nach dem Krieg zum Beispiel.
Und jetzt haben wir uns aber nach diesem Krieg eben über Jahrzehnte schön in,
einer relativ gemütlichen Situation bequem gemacht. Und jetzt ist es halt nicht
so einfach. Du siehst ja, wie groß die Widerstände sind.
Alle sagen, ja die Umwelt, wir müssen ja irgendwas für die Umwelt tun,
aber am Ende tut halt keiner was für die Umwelt.
Und niemand ist irgendwie bereit. Alle klagen über alles Mögliche,
aber wenn du sagst, ja dann fangen wir doch mal hier mit den Parkplätzen an,
dann ist es also sofort Mistgabeln und Fackeln und so weiter und es geht überhaupt nicht.
Und ja, ich glaube, es muss einfach noch eine Weile schlechter werden,
bevor es besser wird. Weil,
Alles, was bisher passiert ist, hat nicht ausgereicht. Kannst du einfach nur,
alle in den Sack und drauf hauen.
Hauswandern, ich guck mal, wo es schön ist.
Ja, das ist, die anderen sind auch scheiße.
Woanders ist es auch scheiße.
Woanders ist es auch scheiße. Jetzt machen wir hier Schluss.
Schluss mit Deutschland. Schluss mit der Sendung. Wir werden das auch weiterhin begleiten.
Mal gucken. Vielleicht tut sich ja da noch was. Vielleicht liegen wir ja auch
mal falsch. Wäre ja auch mal ganz schön.
Ich weiß, das passiert nicht.
Das passiert nicht.
Ja, das wäre.
Jetzt für mich.
War nur ein Witz.
Sag ich mal so ein bisschen unsicheres Terrain.
Uncharted Territory. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dem gegenüber offen bin.
Siehst du mal, nicht reformfähig. Das ist so, was ich gesagt habe.
Ne, ne, da haben wir schon immer so gemacht. Da bleib mal bei.
Okay, Leute. Das war's von uns. Bis bald. Tschüss.